So, jetzt mal warten bis Twitch mitgekriegt hat, dass der Stream online ist.
Ach komm mal so viele Leute, Musik zu laut, das Stream geht ja noch gar nicht los.
So, oh heute war, heute war IHK Prüfung, kann das sein?
In welchem Bundesland oder ist das global?
Das ist das mittlerweile global, überall die gleiche Prüfung, haben wir alle am gleichen
Tag in ganz Deutschland oder wie ist das?
Ein Jahr Stream, oh der Sebaro hier, 12.500, excellent subscription, massive, ein Jahr
dabei und First Level Sub, ne Gründer Sub heißt, First Level Sub, First Level Sub war
ja fast schon eine Beleidigung.
Okay, also wie war die Prüfung so?
Fizi, GA1, schwerste überhaupt, was kam denn dran?
Es sagt jeder Jahrgang, dass ihre Prüfung die schwerste ist, das ist genauso wie die
Leute sagen, Bayern Abitur beste und die anderen kommen an, ah ja, Ausbildung in Hessen, lull,
ist immer das gleiche, also jeder Jahrgang sagt, seine Abschlussprüfung ist die schwerste,
meine war auch die schwerste, ganz klar.
Vollkorn Mischbrot, vier Monate, excellent subscription, Dankeschön.
Die Zeit ist immer knapp, deswegen kannst du ja auch eine Sache streichen, wobei, nee,
kannst du nicht mehr, ne?
Erzähl mal, was kam denn so dran, was kam denn in der Abschlussprüfung so dran?
Spielst du auch Last of Us 2, nee, hab ich noch nicht gekauft, weiß gar nicht, läuft
das auf meiner normalen Playstation überhaupt, auf meiner nicht Playstation 4 Pro, ohne dass
er explodiert?
Erzähl mal, was kam denn so dran, haben ja anscheinend ein paar heute Abschlussprüfungen
gemacht.
Klassischer Datenbank SQL Pseudocode, ok.
Netzplan ok, danach zweimal Pseudocode, dann Datenbank Zeug, jedoch.
Wisst ihr, warum jeder denkt, dass seine Prüfung die schwerste Prüfung ist?
Weil er dann selbst in der Prüfung sitzt und es eine ganz andere Situation ist, als
wenn du dir einfach im Vorfeld eine Prüfung anguckst, als wenn du wirklich in der Prüfung
drin sitzt.
Das ist aber eine ganze Ecke mehr belastend.
Die Prüfungen sind jedes Jahr gleich dämlich, und anders als dämlich kann man die IHK-Prüfung
eh nicht bezeichnen, die IHK-Prüfungen sind richtig, richtig low-brain, Alter.
Die Zeit hat gefehlt, ich bin auch nicht fertig geworden mit der Abschlussprüfung, das ist
normal, dass man, oder, dass man nur ganz knapp fertig wird, wenn überhaupt.
Das ist ein Unterschied, ob man Prüfungsvorbereitung macht oder ob man wirklich in der Prüfung
sitzt.
Das ist glaube ich der große Unterschied.
Ja, das kriegst du schon, also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung hat,
man kann eigentlich bei der Abschlussprüfung gar nicht richtig durchfallen.
Und ich mir gucke, was für Volldämmen schon die Abschlussprüfung geschafft haben bei
der IHK.
Das sagt ja gar nichts, ja, also insofern, ich weiß, dass ihr euch alle ein bisschen
auskennt, für euch ist das easy as fuck gewesen, das zu bestehen.
Wie ist das eigentlich, wenn man die Abschlussprüfung, quasi, durchfällt und 95% dann irgendwie
in der mündlichen hat, geht das?
Ja, Taze, und wie wars, du bist doch nicht der Einzige, du bist doch nicht der Einzige,
wie wars?
Erzähl mal.
Wenn ein Teil unter 30% ist, dann ist es vorbei, ach grad, ihr habt alle über 30%.
Der Chat, allein schon, dass ihr Teil des seid, bedeutet ja automatisch, also insofern,
Big Brain ist hier an der Tagesordnung.
Äh, doof, ich hab mir auch überlegt, ob ich mir das Board kaufen soll, wir hatten das
gefragt.
Sebao, ich hab mir auch überlegt, oh das ist ein neuer, plus, oh der ist neu, den kenn
ich noch gar nicht, den alten wollte ich nicht, aber doch, den nehm ich, doch, das ist immer
noch das gleiche.
Was ich an dem doof fand, oh, 2,5G, das ist tatsächlich ziemlich gut, das hab ich nicht
gesehen, also die normale Variante war doof, weil der Formfaktor von diesem Board absolut
nichts gibt, wo das reinpasst.
Das war das Problem, ich hab mir das Board auch angeguckt, allerdings die nicht plus
Variante, die normale Variante, mit 2,5G Anschlüssen ist das ziemlich gut, muss ich sagen.
Dann fällt es auch nicht so ins Gewicht, dass der keinen PCIeXpress Anschluss hat für
eine 10G Karte und man muss hier auch keine Hacks machen mit M2 auf PCIeXpress und so
ein Geschiss.
Das ist RAM, das ist M2, zwei SATA Anschlüsse, das ist sogar ziemlich gut, was ist da für
eine CPU drauf?
Ja, gut, da wird kein großer Unterschied zu sein, sind vier Kerne, vier Kerne Zeleron.
Kann dein 10G Switch auch 2,5G?
Ich glaub schon, die meisten können es mittlerweile mit Firmware Updates.
Ja, doch, kann er, ich hab sogar mal nachge- ja, ja, kann er.
Ja, da haben sie recht, also die Kombination aus zwei mal SATA, M2 auf der Rückseite, ganz
ordentliche CPU, vor allem das ganz tolle an dieser CPU ist, an diesen Low Budget CPUs
sind, was sie für ein NAS System extrem gut machen ist, die haben Hardware Encryption,
also die haben Hardware Krypto-Gedöns von Intel mit eingebaut.
Ja, also die Kombination aus 2,5G, das ist ein ziemlich guter NAS-Bild.
Warum man zwei mal 2,5G hat, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht hätte man eine PCI-Express-Lane
lieber noch für was anderes verwenden sollen, wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, mir fällt
jetzt gerade nicht ein für was, man hätte hier irgendwie an die Seite noch einen PCI-Express
dockern können oder so, keine Schimmer, aber an sich ist das ziemlich gut, kostet, Preis,
ich wollte mir nämlich das Board letztens sogar mal kurz kaufen, also das alte, das
war es nicht lieferbar und dann ist mir aufgefallen, eigentlich will ich es auch überhaupt nicht
haben, weil der Formfaktor kacke ist, kann er immer noch eMMC, also das Ding ist ein super
Formfaktor, das einzige Problem dabei ist, es gibt kein Gehäuse, wo du es reinkriegst.
Tanzer, oh guck mal, du hast ein Abo-Geschenk gekriegt, exellent, Abo-Distribution hier,
für die scheiß Prüfung, tja vielleicht munter dich das ja etwas auf, selbst Gehäuse
drucken, ja das ist doof, ich brauche irgendwas, wo ein Wechselrahmen reinpasst für zwei Festplatten
oder so, aber rein von den Hardware-Stats ist das das beste Selbstbau-Nass-Gehäuse,
was es gibt zurzeit, ja, also Sebaro, das hast du, aber hast du was gutes ausgebuddelt,
besser als das letzte auf jeden Fall, so wie es aussieht gibt es das allerdings noch
nicht, guckt euch das doch mal an, ich wollte mich verarschen, was soll denn das sein, ist
das eine Kloschüssel mit Lüfter oder was, das ist ja mal, meine Oma hätte jetzt gesagt,
das ist der Griff zum wegschmeißen hier neben, das ist schlechter, ok was kostet der Kram,
als würde es den kosten, wenn man es importiert, achso ich wollte jetzt mal gucken, was hat
in der Chat noch geschrieben zur Abschlussprüfung, GH1 Teil 1 gestrichen, real unperfekt, du
bist in guter Gesellschaft, ich hab auch GH1 Teil 1 gestrichen, GH1 Teil 1 war Netzwerkverkabelung,
bei mir, wie wars bei euch, Kofax zwei Monate, exzellent, Dankeschön für den Sub, kurz
durchscrollen, da ich nix vergesse hier, ich hab halt zum Glück Scrollbackbuffer von 2000
Zeilen, also bei mir war GH1 Teil 1 war Verkabelung, nix IP Shit sondern wirklich Gebäudeverkabelung
und da hatte ich keinen Bock, die Rechenaufgaben werden immer sehr großzügig ausgelegt in
der ERK Prüfung, also da ist es teilweise sogar egal ob du an der Stelle richtig mit
1000 oder 1024 rechnest, da gilt beides, also die sind da sehr großzügig, du hast doch
ein 3D Drucker, ja hab ich aber selbst gedruckte Gehäuse, das ist vielleicht für einen Microcontroller
ESP32 gut, aber doch nicht für sowas hier, ach du hattest heute Abschlussprüfung komplett
oder was, ach nee du hattest mündliche Prüfung vorausschriftlich wegen Corona oder sowas
kann das sein, hatten ja ein paar Leute, normalerweise ist es ja immer umgedreht, ach exzellent,
das heißt wenn nicht dein Betrieb ausgebeutet hat gehst du woanders hin, Tainser sowas kommt
doch in der ERK Abschlussprüfung nicht dran, das ist viel zu advanced, ja da bin ich mal
gespannt was bei euch allen so rauskommt noch, also ich zeige euch mal was wir heute machen,
zwar ich hab vorhin gelesen, dass Open Media Vault 5 rausgekommen ist, im Moment erst mal
hier Dark Mode kurz ausmachen, hat jemand von euch schon mal Open Media Vault verwendet?
Also ich hab es mal ganz kurz probiert, auf, wo war denn das, ich glaube auch auf so einem
Celeron Board, wo ich da hab ich mir 3 Stück gekauft mal, hab ich auch verwendet, mir hat
die letzte Version jetzt nicht ganz so gut gefallen, das war ein Frontend, im Endeffekt
was ich verwendet hätte um Samba aufzusetzen, was jetzt eigentlich kein großes Hexenwerk
ist wozu ich kein Frontend brauche, dazu nehme ich halt nach wie vor lieber ein nackiges
Ubuntu und mach drauf was ich brauche, aber ich glaube für Leute die quasi ein fix und
fertiges Nass Distribution haben wollen und einfach nur was inszenieren und es funktioniert
ist das gar nicht so schlecht, und ich werde das heut mal auf dem Raspberry Pi 4 ausprobieren
weil das ist ja ein System was ich immer flamee, wenn es um die Tauglichkeit für Nass geht.
Da guck mal wie der sich schlägt, wie gesagt ich bin immer auch der Meinung dass der Raspberry
Pi 4 ein schlechtes, schlechte Grundlage für Nass ist, außer für einen sehr sehr low budget
low performance Nass, äh Tobix ist auch so, ja ist auch so, richtig, ähm warum ich den
Raspberry Pi nicht mag als Nass Grundlage ist relativ schnell gesagt, das Ding hat keinerlei
Krypto Extensions, die CPU hätte eigentlich welche, allerdings haben die sich gedacht
naja das lizenzieren wir nicht oder bauen wir nicht rein oder was auch immer, also sprich
die CPU hat keine Beschleunigung für Verschlüsseln, Entschlüsseln, Hashes und sonst was drinnen,
das ist ziemlich doof, gerade für einen Nass, das sorgt dafür dass die CPU komplett am Limit
ist, wenn man, die ist auch so schon ziemlich am Limit, aber wenn man die Festplatte oder
sei es die SSD oder Festplatte ist ja egal, wenn man die verschlüsselt hat was eigentlich
fast schon Standard sein sollte, ich behaupte auch mal Standard ist wahrscheinlich bei den
meisten Nass Systemen, dass man einfach keine großartigen Geschwindigkeiten über mehr kriegt
weil die CPU komplett am Limit ist, der Raspberry Pi muss dann IOU machen auf die Platte, eventuelle
RAID schräg schräg ZFS Geschichten machen, Samba IOU Samba Netzwerk Traffic machen und
Verschlüsseln Entschlüsseln, der Raspberry Pi 4 hat zwar halbwegs schnelle 4 Kerne aber
die sind halt für sowas nicht schnell genug, übrigens das Board was der Sebaro hier ausgebuddelt
hat, das da ist um Längen besser geeignet für sowas, weil es hat nicht nur eine deutlich
schnellere CPU drinne als der Raspberry Pi, obwohl es der Low End Low Budget Celeron ist,
nein die CPU hat auch die Intel Krypto Extensions was dazu führen wird, dass die CPU kaum Last
hat rein vom Fair und End Schlüsseln, es ist aber auch teurer, das ist die Frage was
man haben will, es ist ungefähr doppelt bis dreifach so teuer, dafür ist es auch doppelt
bis dreifach so schnell und es hat SATA Anschlüsse kommt auch noch dabei, wobei man mit dem Raspberry
Pi 4 und seinem ordentlich angebundenen USB 3 noch halbwegs was auf die Reihe kriegt,
um Sachen anzuschließen, ich hab grad Ubuntu 14.04 gelesen, nein ich hatte kein Odroid
HC2, ah so Moment, HC2 hatte ich schon, HC2 ist aber was komplett anderes, also die Benahmung
ist auch ein bisschen Low Brain von denen, also die Benahmung von denen ist ziemlich
von Arsch, also wer jetzt denkt, dass ein Odroid H2 Plus was ähnliches ist wie ein Odroid
HC2 liegt komplett falsch, das hier ist eine ganz normale Intel Plattform, ganz normale
4 Kern Celeron Intel CPU hier drauf, x86 und das hier ist ein 8 Kerne, 8 Kerne Arm fragt
mich nicht gedöns, aber der ist deutlich besseres nass als der Raspberry Pi, ja, letztendlich
ist es wie immer man kriegt wofür man bezahlt, aber hier ist performance-mäßig die Sache
besser als auf dem Raspberry Pi, Arm vs x86, die Frage stellt sich ja meistens gar nicht,
also beim Stromverbrauch ganz klar Arm, beim Strom für Leistung auch noch Arm, aber bei
halbwegs normaler Leistung die man braucht, dann bleibt ja aus x86 viel anderes übrig,
ich mein das Ding hier ist der billigste vom billigsten 4 Kern Celeron den Intel hat und
das Ding ist 5 mal schneller als den Raspberry Pi oder so, oder noch oder mehr, keine Ahnung,
ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht wieviel schneller, aber viel schneller auf jeden Fall, kuck mal
nochmal, kuck mal nochmal was der für ein Benchmark hat vs, was ist noch mal drinne
im Raspberry Pi, das ist mir klar dass das schneller ist, Benchmarkergebnisse, ah exzellent,
er erkennt ja alles sofort, ich hoffe ihr könnt das auch gut lesen, was ist denn mit
der Seite los, what the fuck, was ist das für ne scheiß Seite, was ist das hier unten ok,
ja Moment da ist doch das Intel Ding gar nicht drinne, doch, what the fuck, was sehe ich hier
überhaupt, was sehe ich hier überhaupt, ok glaubt's mir einfach das Ding ist schneller,
also aus dem Benchmark werde ich jetzt wirklich nicht schlau, vielleicht haben die hier irgendwelche
Benchmarks oder so, hier Benchmarks, oh ich mache ungern Google Dokumente auf, ja also
und sind wir dann hier single threaded, 4 threads, das kann nicht sein, dass das gleiche
Resultat hat, das ist Schwachsinn, der war irgendwie AIO limitiert oder sonst was, Suspension,
wo hat er einen Suspension dabei, ah hier, was ist denn heute los, warum sehen die ganzen
Benchmark Seiten so unleserlich aus, Suspension, ja, ich wäre aus dem Ergebnis nicht schlau,
was sagt mir das jetzt, ah, es dauert 9 Millisekunden auf dem Raspberry Pi und 0,69 Millisekunden
auf dem, auf der Celeron CPU oder was, was ist das für ein bescheuerter Benchmark, können
wir nicht irgendwas ordentliches mal ausprobieren, ach ja ok, das ist dann nochmal ganz gut,
das ist wahrscheinlich auch Single Core oder nicht, oder wahrscheinlich schon und zumindest
das ein Kern ist schon mal hier doppelt so schnell, wie der vom Raspberry Pi, das Ding
ist viel schneller, ja, wie der, also viel viel schneller, ChillimEgg sagt, ich habe
noch eine HC2 rumliegen, ist es egal, was für eine Platte ich einbaue, ja, ja, ist es
egal, auch ein bisschen laut die Musiker, weil geht eigentlich, so, was wollte ich jetzt
noch sagen, genau, wir werden nämlich den Raspberry Pi verwenden, den wir das letzte
mal auf SSD Boot umgestellt haben, den habe ich nämlich noch hier rumliegen, das heißt
wir müssen jetzt keinen Raspberry Pi oder sonst was, keinen Raspbian installieren, ich
habe noch den Raspberry Pi mit der, wir machen einfach ein paar Updates drauf, dass das auch
das aktuelle Build ist und dann installieren wir auch ein Media Vault drauf und dann habe
ich noch eine zweite SSD mit USB Adapter und dann gucken wir mal wie schnell das ganze
geht und wie einfach die Verwaltung damit ist über das Web Interface, wir können auch
gleich mal gucken wie man den Kram auf Raspberry gescheit installiert bekommt, kann man pauschal
nicht sagen, es ist die Frage, was das haben soll, an Ausfallfähigkeit, an Performance,
wie teuer die Platten sein sollen, wie viel Platz du brauchst, also das kann man so pauschal
nicht sagen was eine gute Sache für ein Raspbian ist, also ich habe aktuell ein Intel 4 Kern
Celeron Board am Start mit Low Power Plattformen, die brauchen ungefähr 10 Watt, wenn die Platten
Eidl sind mit einer 10G PCI Express Karte und die kriege ich zwar nicht komplett ausgelastet
mit der Kiste, aber so die Hälfte ungefähr, kann man mit Open Media Vault auch Raid oder
Unraid einrichten, Na Unraid nicht, aber Raid kannst du damit garantiert einrichten, das
ist ein Fehler im Web Interface, das werden wir gleich sehen, also als erstes muss ich
mal meinen Raspberry Pi anschließen, wir starten mal unser Bastel Linux, ist Open Media Vault
eine Freenas Alternative, ich glaube die ZFS Verwaltung mit Open Media Vault ist nicht
so toll, das müssen wir uns aber gleich mal angucken, weil es hat sich da bestimmt viel
getan, also Freenas war halt für ZFS das beste, wenn man ordentliches ZFS mit Frontend haben
wollte, wobei ich ja auch mir das angeguckt habe, aber relativ schnell gesagt habe, nee
ich brauch kein Freenas, ich nehme ein aktuelles Ubuntu und mach Open ZFS oder ZFS und Linux
drauf und mach die Verwaltung halt von Hand, aber wenn man quasi ein gemanagtes ZFS haben
will mit Web, viel zu laut die Musik, ja Nintendo regt euch ab, ist Open Media Vault leichtgewichtig,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab es noch nicht installiert, so und deswegen, ich hab den
ganzen Kram alles ausprobiert, von Rockstore bis Freenas bis Open Media Vault und ich bin
immer dabei hängen geblieben, dass ich gesagt hab, hey für ein bisschen Zamba Setup und
für ein bisschen Verwaltung was Raid und Platten angeht, brauch ich kein Webfrontend
wozu, ich weiß wie der Kram funktioniert und das was ich da ein paar mal im Jahr machen
muss, solange man sein Backup automatisch hat was irgendwo singt, wozu brauch ich ein Webfrontend?
Deswegen probieren wir das jetzt mal aus, ich schließe jetzt den Raspberry Pi an, warte
mal kurz, hier ist er, muss ich mal kurz das Stromstecker abmachen, warte mal, voll die
Kabelfähr verknodet irgendwie, exzellent, was bootet, geht er, also an ist er, schauen
wir mal ob er angeht, der Chat erinnert sich doch bestimmt noch an die IP, die ich dem
Raspberry gegeben hab oder, ne wahrscheinlich erinnert sich da keiner mehr dran, da muss
ich mal kurz dem Router nachgucken was der DHCP mäßig kriegt, ja, ja da ist er SSH
high at 230, wat, what, wie da ist kein SSH drauf
tatsächlich, ist doch kein SSH, haben wir das noch nicht verwendet um uns irgendwo drauf
einzuloggen, echt nicht, ok, tatsächlich anscheinend nicht, ja gut, man lernt nicht
aus ja anscheinend haben wir die andere vm immer dafür verwendet, no route to host,
das kann überhaupt nicht sein und irgendwas stimmt hier nicht, irgendwas ist hier fail
gerade, geht das Internet, Moment, ach Moment, die IP ist falsch, ja kein Wunder dass es
nicht funktioniert, wenn man es richtig macht dann geht es auch, SSH copy ID, ist das auch
nicht, ach ich hab keine, wie ich hab keine Keys generiert oder was, echt nicht, warte,
warum hab ich den ganzen Kram nicht da drauf, sagen gibt's, gut, wir hinterfragen das jetzt
nicht so sehr, wir machen das jetzt einfach und gut ist, kio kun sagt er wurde gestern
im Zoom Chat gerickrolled, das ist doch ein Ding oder was, gerickrolled, das ist wenn
man Rick Ashley, wie heißt das, never gonna give you up oder so spielt, man muss mit irgendwas
anfangen was nach was anderem aussieht und dann muss man Rick Ashley abspielen, das muss
man nicht kennen, das ist Boomer Zeug eigentlich, Rickrollen, so wir updaten das Ding jetzt
erstmal und dann gucken wir wie man Open Media Vault installieren, Open Media Vault Raspberry
Pi, was gibt's denn da für einen Guide, Heise, wir hatten einen Guide, ich hab's gelesen
dass die irgendwo einen Guide hatten, Installation Images, wie gesagt wir installieren gar kein
ISO, ich glaub der Guide war hier drinnen, verlinkt genau, exzellent, Installing Open
Media Vault on Raspberry Pi, Model 2 and up, wir haben den Model 4, das passt, gut, da
steht drinnen was wir machen müssen, Upped, Upgrade, bäm, wunderbar, yes, mach mal, so
also wie installiert man das ganze, bla bla bla bla bla bla bla, wir haben ja schon fertig
es installiert das Raspbian, das brauchen wir alles gar nicht, das brauchen wir alles
gar nicht, Raspbian Boot, First Time, haben wir alles schon fertig, so, before installing
Open Media Vault, update and upgrade Raspbian using the following commands, machen wir gerade,
Kyokon 12 Mona, dankeschön, exzellent, Hackermans hier wieder, Big Brained, der Chat, ist die
Musik wieder zu leise, also die Abmischung von dieser Playlist ist irgendwie ziemlich
der Sack, was haben wir denn sonst noch für Alternative, so was da, Wupp Wupp Wupp, okay
lassen wir sowas laufen, ist auch okay, Hauptsache es ist nicht zu laut, es ist ungefähr gleichmäßig
laut, das reicht mir schon, dass es nicht einmal auf der einen Seite die Leute ins Ohr schreiten
und auf der anderen Seite dann zu leise ist, das geht jetzt glaube ich, so, lassen wir
den Raspbian updateen, übrigens das geht sau schnell, seitdem wir von der SSD booten,
plutscht, richtig von der SSD, was hältst du von Brave, nix mehr, weil habe ich kein Anwendungszweck
mehr für, gibt für alles was Brave kann jetzt bessere Alternativen, SSD Boot ist aus der
Beta raus, ja okay, dann wird es das hier wahrscheinlich jetzt auch offiziell machen
und man Beta Zeug rausschmeißen, wir gucken mal kurz von wo wir gestartet haben, wir sind
gebootet von SDH1, okay, wir sind von der, sind, also das Boot-Petition ist hier von
der SSD, das heißt der Rest wird wahrscheinlich auch von der SSD sein, ja, 222G, das ist garantiert
nicht von der, ist garantiert nicht von der SSD, von der MicroSD, so, wir haben geupdatet,
so, was sollen wir jetzt machen, etc, network, warum sollte ich das machen, warum sollte
ich das machen, was macht das, etc, was, etc, systemd, dann was, network, 99, also link ist
wahrscheinlich ein Link, ja, def0, exzellent, alles klar, okay, übrigens ist auch sehr big
brain gemacht, dass man eine Anleitung online stellt, die man nicht, achso, das ist ein
PDF, das ist ein PDF, was GitHub gerendert hat, für mich, na gut, gut, also das sollen
wir löschen, ich weiß nicht was es macht ehrlich gesagt, aber wir machen das einfach
mal, so, Installing Open Media Vault, jetzt sollen wir rebooten, rebooten, hoffentlich
geht jetzt mein Interface noch ab, wenn ich, wenn ich reboote, schauen wir mal, so, und
dann sollen wir Open Media Vault installieren, Leute, heute, während, während der Raspberry
Pi rebooted, na, alter, war Twitter heute wieder ätzend, ich hab echt an der, an der
Zurechnungsfähigkeit der Menschheit gezweifelt wieder, es ist Wahnsinn auf Twitter wieder,
sie drehen alle komplett am Rad, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich davon jetzt überhaupt anfangen
soll im Stream, okay, also, ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt, in Bremen haben Polizisten jemand
erschossen, so, das war der Stein des Anstoßes heute auf Twitter, wo sich alle wieder aufgeregt
haben, so, und das hat jemand gefilmt, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht habt ihr es auch gesehen,
das war ja überall in den Nachrichten, ja, es hat jemand gefilmt, vom Balkon aus, man
hat halt gesehen, vier Polizisten stehen auf dem Hof, und ihnen gegenüber steht ein Mann
mit so einer Art Machete in der Hand, mit einem recht großen Messer, ja, und die sagen
ihm halt, Messer weg, Messer weg, Messer weg, Messer weg, Messer weg, und, ja gut, er macht
ja eigentlich gar nichts, außer mit dem Messer rumfuchteln, Messer weg, dann wird der Pfeffer
gesprayt, und Messer weg, Messer weg, der legt das Messer nicht weg, und dann stürmt
er auf die Polizei zu, und so ein paar Meter, ein paar Meter, bevor er bei dem einen Polizisten
schießt, schießt er ihm halt ins Bein, zweimal, so, dann fällt er um, später ist der verblute
da dran, gut, das finde ich jetzt nicht gut, aber ich frag mich halt so, okay, was hätte
der Polizist machen sollen, so, und Twitter ist jetzt der Meinung, das war ein schwarzer,
aber das darf man, darf man, sorry, darf man nicht sagen, das war ein, wie heißt das jetzt
korrekt, Pock, ich tue mir mit manchen Wörtern auch schwer, ja, Pock, eigentlich vollkommen
unrelevant für diese, für diese ganze Geschichte, ob das ein schwarzer oder ein weißer war,
weil im umgekehrten Fall wird ja auch immer argumentiert, warum wird, wird die Nationalität
bei Tätern genannt, warum wird sie nicht genannt, in dem Fall ist es jetzt anscheinend
wichtig gewesen, so, und zumindest, das war ein schwarzer und deswegen haben, regen sich,
haben sich heute auf Twitter alle Leute wieder wahnsinnig aufgeregt, mal gucken, ob der Raspberry
Pi da ist, aus mir nicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen, nachdem man dieses Video gesehen
hat, dass die Polizei da wahnsinnig rassistisch gehandelt hätte, der Typ ist mit der Machete
auf die Polizei zu gerannt, hätte der Polizist sagen sollen, ach easy, er stecht mich, alles
gut, ich meine, wer, wer im öffentlichen Raum mit einem Messer oder einer Machete oder
einer Axt, wir hatten ja letztens, gab es ja hier, war das nicht, das können sogar Frankfurt
und Umgebung gewesen, ich glaube, das war sogar Frankfurt, wo einer mit der Axt durch
den, durch den Zug gerannt ist, den haben sie auch erschossen, oder angeschossen, da
ist nicht gestorben, wir haben es angeschossen, der ist mit der Axt durch den Zug gerannt
und wollte Leute erschlagen, also ich denke, wer, wer sowas macht, der muss doch damit
rechnen können, dass es nach hinten losgeht, und unabhängig davon, ob sich der Täter in
geistiger Umnachtung befindet, ob er besoffen ist, unter Drogen Einfluss oder sonst was,
was soll denn der Polizist machen, da kommt einer mit der Machete auf ein Los gestürmt,
hätte er ihn umarmen sollen und sagen, ja alter, alles gut, Leben wird auch wieder besser,
ich hole mal, ich rufe mal eine Psychologe an, hätte er machen können, auch vielleicht
ein Messer im Bauch stecken gehabt, also, ich sag ja immer, ich finde es gut, wenn es
über Diskussionen gibt, über aktuelle Ereignisse und man sich auch über kontroverse Sachen
unterhält, anstatt pauschal zu sagen, es sind Verschwörungstheorien oder irgendwie
linkes Recht, das war es auch immer, Gedankengut, sondern einfach sich darüber unterhält,
das finde ich prinzipiell immer gut, in dem Fall ist es auch vollkommen okay, dass man
darüber diskutiert, ob man sich, die Polizisten nicht hätten anders verhalten können, ob
nicht die Voraussetzungen besser gewesen sein können, was auch immer, finde ich vollkommen
okay, sich darüber zu unterhalten, aber ich kann nicht verstehen, dass es überhaupt so
viele Leute gibt, die zu einer anderen Entscheidung kommen, als dass der Polizist vollkommen
rational richtig und komplett korrekt gehandelt hat, was soll der denn machen, ich meine,
ich habe keinerlei sinnvolle andere Erklärung dafür, was der hätte machen sollen, naja,
zumindest das beste Kommentar, was ich dazu gefunden habe und das war ernst gemein, das
war wirklich, das muss ich euch mal zeigen, das war ernst gemein, das ist so fail, da
habe ich sogar drauf geantwortet, ich antworte auf solche Sachen nie, ich antworte auf zusammen
nie, aber da übrigens, wenn ihr in Wuppertal lebt und Katzen aufnehmen könnt, guckt mal
hier, die suchen neues zu Hause, ja, so, passt mal auf, ich habe da drauf geantwortet, also,
wir lesen uns das Geschwätz da oben gar nicht durch, wir lesen uns den Kram da gar nicht
durch, nur das Kommentar von ihm, das meint der ernst, man kann auch 4 Polizisten einfach
mit Riot Shield geben und damit kesseln sie den Typen mit dem Messer ein, dauert vielleicht
etwas, aber relativ ungefällig für Angriffe und sehr sicher für die Polizei, also sprich,
da steht ein Typ mit der Machete auf dem Hof in einem Wohngebiet, legt auf wiederholte
Aufforderungen die Waffe nicht weg, stürmt mit der Machete auf einen Polizist zu und
die Hand, also das was die Polizisten hätten machen sollen, ist, sich alle 4 mit dem Riot
Shield schnappen und den Gegner stunnen, oder was, what the fuck, dass man sowas überhaupt
ernst meinen kann, ist mir absolut unbegreiflich, ich muss halt was dummes darauf antworten,
wir hätten gleich Flashbangs stunnen und dann 360 vom anderen Dach, der hat ja noch
darauf geantwortet, so nach dem Motto, nein, nein, ich mein das ernst, what the fuck, mir
fehlen die Worte für die Realitätsfernheit mancher Leute und da hat jemand anderes noch
geschrieben, weil der Raspberry Pi ist fertig, warum haben Polizisten überhaupt Patronen
in der Pistole und da wollte ich darauf antworten, ja wegen genau sowas, ich antworte ja ungern
auf Twitter auf sowas, weil du dich relativ schnell dort dem Mob aussetzt, da eskaliert
ist ja ganz schnell auf Twitter, genau sowas haben die Patronen in der Pistole, weil wenn
du im Einsatz bist als Polizist und kommt einer mit dem Messer auf dich zugestürmt,
ist besser wenn du dich verteidigen kannst, ja, und dann kam danach doch im gleichen Tweet
stand dann anstatt Patronen hätten die auch Betäubungsfeile in die Pistole machen sollen,
ich frage mich echt, wie komplett Realitätsfern können manche Leute sein, was sollen die
denn da für Betäubungsfeile rein machen, die so schnell wirken wie Pistolenkugeln,
also ich denke mal das effektivste was die da rein machen könnten wird vordereck eine
halbe Minute dauern bis es richtig wirkt, oder aber sie ballern ihm gleich sowas rein,
dass er auch dran stirbt und selbst dann stoppt halt der Betäubungsfeil, das sieht man ja
schon wenn die im Zoo irgendwie was einfangen wollen, die Tiere kriegen den Betäubungsfeil
ab und dann dauert es ein viertel Stunde bis die ran können, ja, wie soll das gehen,
ich kann nicht nachvollziehen, es erschließt sich mir einfach überhaupt nicht, wie Leute
sowas ernst meinen können, wie gesagt ich sag immer Diskurs ist wichtig aber ich verstehe
nicht wie man das ernst meinen kann und ich verstehe auch nicht wie man gerade, wir gucken
uns das Video übrigens nicht an, man sieht in dem Video nichts, die haben vom Balkon
gefilmt und man hört halt nur zwei Schüsse und er fällt um, also es spritzt auch kein
Blut oder so, aber das gucken wir uns sicher, ich glaube das ist Monka, Toss, wie auch immer,
also ich meine gerade jetzt wo man das im Video sieht wie das abgelaufen ist, wie kann
man dazu zu solchen Schlüssen nur kommen, also ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen und was
ich halt auch merkwürdig finde ist, dass alle dazu wieder eine wahnsinnig tolle Meinung
haben aber es keiner irgendwie schlüssig begründen kann was der Polizist hätte anders machen
sollen, da kommen da nur so Sachen wie ein Menschenleben ist gar nichts mehr wert, der
ist mit dem Messer auf die Polizei zu gerannt, da muss man doch sich denken können, dass
es in die Hose geht, um es mal auf hessisch zu sagen und also keine Ahnung was für Leute
abgeht, also da platzt echt mein Kopf dabei, es war kein machin, es war ein großes Messer,
ich warte noch drauf bis mir irgendjemand schlüssig erklären kann was die Polizei
bei dem Angriff hätte großartig anders machen sollen, man kann sich drüber unterhalten
dass man im Vorfeld hätte die Situation vielleicht anders angehen sollen, das weiß man ja in
dem Fall nicht was da vorher gelaufen ist, vielleicht hätte es irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
aber diese Situationen wie man sie sieht im Video kann man aus meiner Sicht nicht anders
beurteilen als dass die Polizei das richtig gemacht hat, ja es spricht auch nichts dagegen
dass man sich überlegt, dass man sowas wie Betäubungsfeile oder so, dass man das als
andere Option noch dabei hat, aber das kann ja schlecht die Pistole ersetzen, bei sowas,
der hat irgendwas gebraucht wo zack bumm und Ruhe ist, Taser wäre auch eine Möglichkeit,
Taser ist allerdings auch nicht so ungefährlich, allerdings auf jeden Fall besser als erschossen
werden, dabei vergisst du völlig dass der tote Schwerp psychisch gestört war, ja das
ist aber dem Messer mit dem man den Polizisten bedroht hat im Endeffekt auch wurscht, ja
das mag sein dass der Typ psychisch gestört ist, schön und gut aber was hätte der in
der Situation anders machen sollen, der steht da, es stehen vier Polizisten vor ihm und
sagen ihm keine Ahnung zwei Minuten lang er soll das Messer weglegen, er macht es nicht
und er rennt mit dem Messer auf den Polizisten zu, das ändert doch daran gar nichts, was
hätte er denn machen sollen und das ist das was ich nicht verstehe, man kann da viel darüber
diskutieren und ich finde es ja immer gut dass man darüber diskutiert, aber mir hat
noch keiner eine schlüssige Erklärung gebracht was der Polizist hätte anders machen sollen,
vor allem wird dann, vor allem wird auch übelst auf der Polizei rumgehackt, man darf
ja nicht vergessen, der hat ihm sogar ins Bein geschossen und das musste er erstmal hinkriegen,
wenn da einer auf dich zugewetzt kommt und du denkst oh fuck gleich sticht der mich ab
und dann den noch ins Bein zu schießen, also so schlecht wie es die Leute auf Twitter
hinstellen kann er die Ausbildung nicht sein, außerdem finde ich den Vergleich der immer
gezogen wird mit den USA vollkommen an den Hahn herbeigezogen, ich will nicht bestreiten
dass es nicht bei uns bei der Polizei auch welche gibt die komplett über die Stränge
schlagen und das sollte auch verfolgt werden, aber die Polizeigewalt in Deutschland kannst
du in keiner Weise mit dem vergleichen was in den USA passiert und aktuell wird das so
auf ein Level gestellt nach dem Motto alle Polizisten überall auf der Welt sind scheiße
und mussten abgeschafft werden, nee ganz ehrlich Ray Jones, nein die stellt sich nicht, er
schreibt wenn vier Polizisten nicht in der Lage sind einen einzelnen zu überwinden
dann stellt sich die Frage nach der Ausbildung, was hätten sie denn machen sollen, sag doch
mal was Konkretes, hätten sie ihn irgendwie mit dem Lasso einfangen sollen oder so, was
hätten sie machen sollen, ich mein die sind sogar rückwärts gelaufen, hätten sie irgendwie
krasse Kung Fu Moves machen sollen und sich dabei schwer verletzen, keine Ahnung, also
ich bin der Ansicht wenn du öffentlich mit dem Messer rumrennst, Leute bedrohst, zum
Angriff ansetzt, dann muss man damit rechnen, dass es nach hinten losgeht und ja wenn der
Typ besoffen ist und der Drohungenhahn sich psychisch gestört, dann hat er vielleicht
diese Weitsicht in dem Moment nicht, das ändert für denjenigen der angegriffen wird
aber nichts, vor allem dass man gleich wieder mit der Rassismus Keule kommen muss, ist voll
überzogen in dem Fall, hat nichts damit zu tun, es zeigt dass du ein anderes Bild von
Polizeiarbeit hast, na gut, ich will keinem irgendwie seine Meinung verbieten wenn du
das denkst, ok, aber ich hab noch nichts gehört was er hätte anders machen sollen.
Hey Wupplos, wahrscheinlich haben schon Leute erwähnt aber ich hatte meine letzte IRK Prüfung
für den fachinformatischen Anwägungsentwicklung, ja waren heute schon ein paar da die gesagt
haben dass Abschlussprüfung war, wollte mich nochmal bei dir bedanken da ich vor 5 Jahren
deine Videos gesehen habe und deswegen vor 3 Jahren anstelle von einem Abitur meine Ausbildung
gestartet habe, das ist wahrlich excellent, hast du es jetzt geschafft bist du durch oder
musst du noch mündliche machen, musst du noch mündliche Prüfung machen oder bist du
durch, End of Function Zero, bin durch, ich muss auf die Ergebnisse machen, hast du bestimmt
bestanden, Chat, Big Brain oder, was meint ihr Chat, Chat hat End of Function Zero bestanden,
na klar, wenn der Chat es schon sagt dann ist es easy, allein schon dass du den Namen hast
End of Function Zero heißt das ist schonmal mehr Big Brain als die meisten anderen nach
5 Jahren Berufserfahrung haben, also insofern ist es vorbei, ja, Verrätst du was du für
ein Abschlussprojekt gemacht hast, bin auch endlich durch ja, KratzTitanToaster69, exzellent
Name, Function Zero, verrätst du was für ein Abschlussprojekt du gemacht hast, was
für ein Abschlussprojekt du gemacht hast, übrigens, was ich noch sagen wollte, genau
habe ich ganz vergessen, mal unabhängig jetzt von diesem einen Vorfall, heute oder heute
morgen, mit dem ich mich gerade ausgelassen habe, ich finde teilweise die Alternativen
die da genannt werden sehr wir, ich habe jetzt schon gehört, so nach dem Motto, ja Polizei
ist scheiße, weil Polizei ist ja pauschal alle rassistisch, vielleicht sollte man nicht
unbedingt immer alle sofort über einen Kamm scheren, weil es ist ja oftmals das was man
der anderen Seite auch gerade vorwirft, zumindest Polizei abschaffen und dann habe ich letztens
tatsächlich ein Video drüber gesehen, da hat jemand erzählt, ja Polizei komplett abschaffen
und das, also es geht nicht nur um die USA, am besten überall, ja, das komplett, brauchen
wir alles nicht mehr und dafür soll man dann quasi Sozialleistungen und Therapeuten und
Behandlung und so für Leute, für die Öffentlichkeit bezahlen, ist ja eine gute Idee prinzipiell,
ist genauso eine gute Idee prinzipiell, wie wir schaffen alles militär auf der Welt ab,
ja, also sprich, wenn sich keiner mehr gegenseitig angreift oder irgendwas böses will, bräuchte
man eigentlich auch kein Militär und alles kein Problem und wir könnten ganz viel Geld
sparen, das Problem ist bloß die Sache, dass es in der Realität leider ein bisschen, leider
muss ich ja echt sagen, ist ja nicht so, dass ich Gewalt gut finden würde, ja, leider anders
aussieht, du hast nach wie vor Leute, die ein bisschen, die unter Größenwahn sind,
gestört sind, Gewalt, geil finden und da brauchst du halt Polizei und Militär, was ist denn
die Alternative, Polizei abschaffen und dann kriegt jemand auf die Fresse gehauen und
kriegt kostenlos eine Schönheits-OP, das ist doch auch, das ist doch komplett Banane,
man kann die Leute auch gerne so eine Schönheits-OP kostenlos bezahlen, da habe ich keine Schmerzen
mit, ja, aber was ist das für eine beknackte Alternative, wäre es nicht besser, wenn die,
wenn dem erst gar nicht auf die Fresse gehauen wird oder wenn das nicht funktioniert, wenigstens
den Typ erwischt wird, der ihm auf die Fresse gehauen hat, dass er keinem anderen mehr auf
die Fresse hauen kann, man kann doch nicht davon ausgehen, dass man durch soziale Leistungen,
sei es durch Sozialarbeiter, Therapeuten, sonst was, jegliche Menschen dazu bringt,
jegliches Gewaltpotenzial zu verlieren, das ist doch komplett weltfremd von sowas auszugehen,
es gibt Leute, die haben einfach einander Waffel und es gibt Leute, die finden es geil,
Gewalt anzuwenden, anderen Leuten Schmerzenschalen sonst was zuzufügen, das werden alle Sozialarbeiter
der Welt nicht lösen können und wenn du halt so Leute hast, dann brauchst du halt sowas
wie Militär und Polizei, du wirst nicht drum herum kommen und die Diskussionen aktuell gehen
in so merkwürdige Richtung, wo ich mir denke, das kann doch nicht der Ernste der Leute sein,
die sowas behaupten, wenn du da 5 Minuten drüber nachdenkst, kommst du doch schon drauf,
dass das in der Praxis nicht funktionieren kann, alles, das kann nicht funktionieren,
das einzige, was das bringt ist und das ist zwar komplett entgegen dem, was die Leute
dann auch eigentlich wollen ist, es würde sogar die Täter mehr schützen als die Opfer,
weil wenn keine Polizei da ist, kein Militär, keine Strafverfolgung, sonst was, wer sorgt
denn dafür, dass der Typ nicht morgen wieder einem auf die Fresse haut, das funktioniert
in der Praxis einfach nicht, was sich da manche Leute zusammenreiben, das kann nicht funktionieren,
es sei denn, die Welt wird über Nacht, folgen sie alle dem Dalai Lama auf Twitter und werden
erleuchtet und sind bessere Menschen, das wird aber nicht passieren, übrigens der Dalai Lama,
ich bin absolut ungläubig, das wisst ihr, ich habe schon öfters gesagt, ist einer der
wenigen auf Twitter, der wirklich sinnvolle Tweets raushaut zum Thema Zusammenleben, was man auch
ein bisschen auf das aktuelle Thema Rassismus und sonst was ausweiten kann und was der sagt,
so mal zusammengefasst ist im Endeffekt, guckt euch mal die Welt von außen an, man wird nichts
mehr erkennen an Unterschieden zwischen wer ist schwarz, wer ist weiß, wer ist diese Religion,
wer ist das, das ist vollkommen unbedeutend und dann erzählt er immer noch so Zeug wie
nach dem Motto Nächstenliebe und Einfühlvermögen, Beste und sowas und da gäbe ich ihm voll und
ganz recht trotzdem, unterm Strich brauchst du Militär und Polizei, weil das nicht alle Leute
so sehen werden und wir gehen es gerade, Dalai Lama genau, ich habe gesagt, dass der einzige
sinnvolle, dass es einer wegen der sinnvollen Sachen auf Twitter postet, übrigens danke für
die Saks, für die Saks, nein für die Subs, Nekorock, zehn Monate dankeschön, excellent
Subscription und eine weitere huge excellent Subscription durch den TobiX9919 für drei
Monate, ja, jetzt bin ich ein bisschen ins Schwätzen gekommen, ich habe jetzt hier auf
am Raspberry Pi Kali weitergemacht, ich sehe der Enigma Code hat noch gepostet, durch das
Militär ist aber auch die Forschung erheblich nach vorne gekommen, ja das stimmt, obbei ich
mir da relativ sicher bin, wir würden das, wenn wir es mal schaffen würden, auch international
ein bisschen mehr an einem Strang zu ziehen, das auch ohne Militär schaffen, aber ja,
das ist in der Vergangenheit auf jeden Fall so gewesen, aber wie gesagt, ich denke nicht,
dass man ganz ohne auskommt.
Atherz, ja da hast du recht, er schreibt, unter Strich hat der Durchschnittsbürger
genauso viel Plan von Informatik wie von Selbstverteilung, Polizei, aber das ist richtig, das auf Twitter
ist halt aber auch, dass die Leute meinen, sie sind Experten und vor allem, dass sie,
selbst wenn sie erkennen, dass sie keine Experten sind, dass sie trotzdem ihre eigenen Aussagen
nicht mal fünf Minuten auf Plausibilität und sei es nur in ihrem eigenen Gehirn checken,
da kommen so ganz bescheuerte Dinger, wo man sich das nach fünf Minuten überlegen will,
das kann nicht gehen, das kann nicht funktionieren, naja, okay, habe ich eigentlich bei der aktuellen
EA Play was verpasst, war doch gestern, FIFA geht mir so am Arsch vorbei, was gab es denn
da Neues, Nox 2702, eigentlich geht es doch gar nicht so sehr ums Gewinnen, also ich weiß,
dass es viele Leute darum geht, möglichst viele andere Leute zu korrigieren und ja natürlich
klopft man sich gerne auf die Schulter, also ich habe abschließend Recht gehabt, das ist
schon klar, aber eigentlich sollte es bei solchen Diskussionen gar nicht so sehr darum
gehen, dass das einer 100% Recht hat und der andere 100% verliert, sondern das, was die
Leute vorwärts bringen, ist eigentlich das, wo man sich trifft irgendwo, weil das ist
dann was, wo beide Seiten mitleben können und das ist das, worauf es in der echten Welt
auch ankommt, nicht das eine Extrem oder das andere Extrem, sondern dass sich beide Seiten
oder die alle Seiten irgendwie auf irgendwas verständigen können, wo alle mitleben können.
Übrigens, Andi Techi spricht was an, genau das sehe ich auch so, was komplett vergessen
wird bei dieser Diskussion ist, wenn man mal davon ausgeht, dass der Polizist ja kein
böser, ausländerhassender Rassist ist, vielleicht macht ihm die Situation, dass er jemand erschießen
muss, da auch ziemlich zu schaffen, da wird nämlich überhaupt nicht drüber gesprochen.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen, ja und das wird komplett ausgeblendet.
Die Polizei preme an einen guten Post, aber die habe ich noch gar nicht gelesen.
Okay, was ist auf der EA Play 2020 rausgekommen?
Apex Legends kommt für die Nintendo Switch, ja das ist auch Source Engine, das läuft ja
nun wirklich mittlerweile überall, aber es sieht wahrscheinlich kacke aus auf der Switch,
wie alles andere auch, was auf der Switch rauskommt, was auf anderen Plattformen schon mal da war
und halbwegs realistisch aussieht, sieht kacke aus.
Okay, was die Polizei preme hat, was gepostet, mal ganz kurz gucken, was hier, wo, das ist
auch unabhängig von meiner Meinung, meine Gedanken und den Kollegen und Kollegen, die
belastende Einsatzsituation ausgesetzt waren, das klingt nach einer rationalen, sinnvollen
Ansicht.
Ich will gar nicht unten drunter lesen, ich traue mich schon nicht, ich traue mich schon
nicht.
Schlimm, wie viel Hass hier in manchen Kommentaren der Polizei entgegen, da muss ich ihm Recht
geben.
Oh Gott, die Leute, Alter, ich kann es nicht lesen, ich kriege Anfälle, ich, nein, ich
lese es nicht, ich lese es nicht, sonst bin ich wieder eine halbe Stunde am mich aufregen
und mich nur über diese Geschichte ausladen.
Was eine bescheuerte Antwort, Alter, die Polizei hat nichts als Verachtung verdient.
Tja, du wirst dich freuen, wenn bei dir mal eingebrochen wird und du rufst die Polizei,
die Polizei sagt, ha, mit, warum sollten wir zu dir kommen, du verachtest doch die Polizei
oder warum ruft ihr überhaupt die Polizei, wenn die Polizei verachtet, ja.
Wie bekommst du sowas in Twitter immer mit aus den Trends, aus den Trends, leider, ich
versuche es ja auszublenden, aber manchmal klicke ich auf so einen Trend drauf und dann
sehe ich einen Kommentar, wie von dem einen, der Messerangreifer mit Riot-Shields umzingeln
will und ich werde immer denken, Leute, was ist mit euch im Hirn los?
Okay, wir sind stehen geblieben, wir wollten auch ein Media Vault auf dem Raspberry installieren,
ne, vorher wollte ich gucken, was es Neues gibt von der EA Play, okay, Apex Legends kommt
für die Switch, sieht wahrscheinlich kacke aus.
Arena-Shooter, das kann man doch heute keinem mehr verkaufen, Star Wars Squadrons, wie spricht
man das richtig aus, Squadrons, Madden und Fifa bekommen die jährliche Neuauflage, nein,
damit hätte ja keiner gerechnet, damit hätte ja wirklich keiner gerechnet, dass EA-Sports-Spiele
eine jährliche Neuauflage bekommen, das, das, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
alles up, alles up, Last of Us, Yay or Nay, ich kaufe mir das noch nicht, aber ansonsten,
wenn ich Fan der Serie wäre, würde ich mir das auf jeden Fall kaufen, Dragon Age 4, okay,
Dragon Age 1 war Massive Poggers, könnte ich echt mal wieder spielen, allerdings nicht
im Stream, der Rest war nicht gut, man munkelt 2020 soll ein Call of Duty rauskommen, was,
wir sind aber die Leaks wieder an der Tagesordnung Leute, real talk, neues Call of Duty 2020,
da hätte ich ja nie mit gerechnet, neues Need for Speed, das wundert mich auch nicht,
DICE Arbeit an einem neuen Battlefield, das wissen wir auch schon, BioWars ist zukünftig
auch etwas zu erwarten, ja es wäre ja auch blöd, wenn die einfach nur da sitzen und
Däumchen drehen, natürlich machen die irgendwas, wie fandet ihr die EA Play Live zu spät,
um 1 Uhr nachts, hätten sie die normal gemacht, zu normalen Zeiten, maximal 23 Uhr, hätten
wir uns die gestern im Stream angeguckt, aber nicht um 1 Uhr nachts, es war wirklich so
gut wie nichts, ja so liest sich die Ankündigung auch aus, so liest sich die Ankündigung auch,
so liest man das auch aus der Ankündigung raus, heute ist deutsche Sätze nicht mein
Ding, die Buchrufe, ne, das gibt ja keine Buchrufe, gibt ja nur, gibt ja nur Klatscher,
die an den richtigen Positionen platziert waren und eins weiß ich aus eigener Erfahrung
von solchen Live Events, so doof es klingt, aber man neigt dazu mit zu klatschen, ich
weiß nicht, ob ihr den Effekt kennt, und nachdem ich wenig auf andere Veranstaltungen gehe,
außer vielleicht mal das ein oder andere Konzert, kann ich da nicht wirklich mitreden, wie das
bei anderen Veranstaltungen ist, aber bei so Gaming Events oder bei Pressekonferenzen
und sonst was, man neigt echt dazu, bei jedem Scheiß mit zu klatschen, ich hab das an mir
selbst gemerkt, am schlimmsten, am schlimmsten war es wirklich, wo wir bei Blizzard gewesen
sind, wo die, ähm, zwar das Legion glaube ich vorgestellt haben, und die Blizzard Fans
sind absolut eskaliert, das hab ich noch nie erlebt, ey, die haben da teilweise Leute
geweint, das war wirklich, die waren fertig mit den Nerven auf jeden Fall, die waren komplett
neben der Spur und dieser, der Hype, die Atmosphäre ist da irgendwie schon mitreißend, ja, also,
man neigt auf solche Veranstaltungen irgendwie mit zu klatschen, deswegen haben die auch
strategisch und ich hab da keinen Beweis für, aber ich bin mir sehr, sehr sicher, dass die
an strategischen Positionen im Publikum, wobei, doch, ich hab einen Beweis für, wir haben
nämlich einen von Microsoft erwischt beim Klatschen, Leute platziert haben, die klatschen,
wenn's angesagt ist, von Microsoft haben wir einen beim Klatschen erwischt, der Felix
besser gesagt hat einen von Microsoft beim Klatschen erwischt, der sah ganz normal aus
und irgendwie hatten der Felix dann angehauen, so nach dem Motto, irgendwie so geil war das
doch nicht, und da hat er gemeint, ja, muss halt klatschen, hat sein T-Shirt hochgehoben,
hat ein Microsoft-Xbox-T-Shirt drunter, das war halt von Microsoft da platziert zum Klatschen,
also, kleinen Beweis dafür gibt's schon, und sie wären auch blöd, wenn sie es nicht
machen würden. Ich fand's witzig, wie der Moderator gehypt
war, die Moderatoren sind mittlerweile extrem overhyped, ich glaube, es gibt keinen mehr,
die solche Veranstaltungen normal moderieren. Könnt ihr euch noch an das Battlefield, Battlefield,
Battlefield 5 Reveal Show da erinnern? Mit, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer hatten das moderiert?
Moment, wer hatten das moderiert? Guck mal, hier übrigens, geiler YouTube-Pack,
wer es nicht kennt. Wir hatten den Kram noch mal moderiert, ok, das war der Trailer. Genau,
er, und die waren allesamt so extrem gehypt, wo ich mir gedacht hab, was ist mit euch los?
Man sieht doch überhaupt nichts. Und der ist die ganze Zeit voll ausgerastet. Es wird,
also, die Moderation von solchen Dingern ist mittlerweile so extrem overhyped, mein, klar,
dafür kriegen die ihr Geld letztendlich. Äh, Wahnsinn. Ok, also, Moment, wir müssen
das PDF hier mal aufmachen. Ich will das eigentlich gar nicht downloaden, ich will das nur im Browser
öffnen. Ja, dann mach halt ein extra Fenster auf. Meinetwegen. Ähm, ich will das nämlich
Copy-Paste, weil ich tipp das, ich tipp das garantiert nicht ab, Installing. Kann man
das nicht, kann man, Alter, PDF-Reader, please, Installing. So. Erstmal, erstmal was nach
Sudo-Bashpipen, exzellent, so, so macht man's. Snoop Dogg Battlefield 1, das waren die besten.
Snoop Dogg Battle, der war geil, den fand ich super. Der einfach nur, sein Joint geraucht
hat und 30 Minuten im Graben gestanden hat, von links nach rechts gelaufen ist in Battlefield
1. Das war der beste. So, wir machen jetzt unseren Raspberry Pi kaputt. Gucken, was passiert.
Ja, ich hab's mal in einem T-Max gestartet, in der Hoffnung, ich brauch's nicht, dass
es abkackt oder so, aber schauen wir mal. Bit, ja, BitConnect, auch sowas. Unsinniges
Gehype, ey. BitConnect war die Gipfel des übertriebenen Hypes, wo wir grad dabei sind.
BitConnect, BitConnect, BitConnect, BitConnect, BitConnect. Das ist so dumm, Alter.
Passive, Exzellent, BitConnect, Soundtrack, Moment.
Das brauche ich, das brauche ich, das brauche ich, das BitConnect Passive Exzellent Soundtrack,
das ist wichtig, das muss ich mir unbedingt installieren später.
Developers, Developers. Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding. Das hab ich euch auch schon mal
gezeigt, die Geschichte. Das ist auch absolut gestört, ey. Das ist aber schon uralt, das
ist wirklich richtig uralt. Der Typ hat auch einen richtigen Knall gehabt,
ey. Aber die Weller passt, die Weller passt, wo kommt das denn? Genau. Die sind alle so
ex, auch grad der Typ ist, der ist, der hat wirklich einen Dachschaden, ey. Der hat auch
immer übelst geschwitzt auf der Bühne. Was macht die Installation? Und sowas war Chef
von Microsoft. Der hatte bestimmt schon eine gewisse Ausstrahlung als Führungspersönlichkeit,
ja. Der hat doch angeblich auch, der Typ, der zu, ich weiß nicht wer, aber müssen wir
mal in Google, müssen wir mal Google, ob es da noch den Eintrag gibt. Ich hab mal gelesen
von jemand, der ist von Microsoft zu Google gewechselt und angeblich hat Steve Ball mal
damals den Stuhl nach ihm geschmissen. I didn't search at Google engineer. Ah, okay,
er hat sich, er hat sich davon distanziert, dass er. Vielleicht stimmt es auch gar nicht.
Vielleicht stimmt es auch gar nicht, ja. Aber das würde ich an seiner Stelle auch sagen,
dass ich keinen Stuhl geschmissen hätte. Das hat man ihm angedichtet. Ich würde es
ihm komplett zutrauen. Es scheint ja keine Belege für zu geben, aber ich würde es ihm
komplett zutrauen. Ich hab's schon echt gestört, Leute. Jetzt ist er doch bei, jetzt hat er
doch ein eigenes Basketball Team oder Baseball Team. Und flippt er angeblich auch ab und
zu mal aus. Oh, Root Passwort leaked. Äh, äh, hash, Root Passwort hash leaked. Sebaro,
was ist denn? Okay, ich bin ja froh, dass ich bei der EA Play nichts verpasst hab. Oder
ich fühle mich darin bestätigt, dass es eine gute Idee war, nicht bis 1 Uhr nachts
aufzubleiben, für im Endeffekt nichts. Der Installer, der ist in der Zwischenzeit, hätt
ich ja komplett das Ubuntu installiert, solange ich das brauch. Macht das da überhaupt? Bei
der Gelegenheit guck ich mal, ob ich irgendwelche Questions übersehen hab. Oh, ganz viel Keg
weh. Ah, nee, mein Memboard ist kaputt. Das ist korrekt. Ja, wie gesagt, richtig gut.
Äh, und Rest haben wir uns schon eigentlich alles angeguckt. Falls ich irgendwas doch
übersehen hab, Leute, schreibt's einfach nochmal, ich seh's dann. Das hackt gerade
dein Netzwerk. Ganz bestimmt. Ganz bestimmt hackt was von mir selbst programmiert gerade,
programmiert das mein eigenes Netzwerk. Warum haben wir eigentlich keinen animierten Hacker-Mans
im Chat? Das Schulprojekt, wonach du vorher gefragt hast? Ja. Oh, echt? Hab ich das übersehen?
Dann schreib nochmal. Dann hab ich wahrscheinlich wirklich übersehen. Exzellent. Als eine die...
Und was? Usul. Ach, das ist der Codename für Open Media Vault, oder wie? Verstehe. Usul.
Hat ein bisschen was von türkischem Getränk, irgendwie so Usul, Iran. Wie so vom Wort her.
Nee, oder eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich klingt es überhaupt nicht ähnlich. Aber heute wieder
richtig, richtig nice Mittagessen. Döner, Pide, Lama, Jun und Iran. Exzellent. Extrem 07 Monate,
danke für die ganzen Streams. Ja, ist doch schön, dass du da bist. Ich freu mich auch.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Pine64? Wenn das dieses Linux-Smartphone ist, traue ich
denen nicht zu, dass da was rauskommt mit nennenswerter Verbreitung. Ich glaube, es
ist, neben iOS und Android wird sich nichts mehr weiter etablieren in nächsten Jahren.
Es sei denn, es gibt irgendwas, was viele Leute haben wollen, was die beiden nicht sinnvoll
abdecken. Es könnte einer sagen Datenschutz. Das interessiert die meisten Leute aber nicht.
Bald schon ein Jahr. Ja, ich bin tatsächlich schon eine ganze Weile Partner, fällt mir
jetzt auf. Danke schön für den Sub. Sag mal, könnte das sein, dass das irgendwie heute
so eine Art Premiere, ähm, nicht Premiere, Jubiläum-Stream ist zufällig? Ich weiß nicht,
wann ich Partner geworden bin, aber irgendwann in der Zeit, jetzt müsste ich Partner geworden
sein von einem Jahr. Da gebe ich dir recht Toaster, ja. Okay, was auch immer der hier
gerade macht. Anscheinend ist es normal, dass, ähm, da einige Fehler im Hintergrund laufen.
Der jetzt fertig? Wann, wann, wann weiß man denn, wann er fertig ist? Okay, dann warten
wir einfach bis er rebooted wird. Kann man sich einen Abo-Verlauf anzeigen? Boah. Ja,
du kannst in dein Paypal-Konto gucken. Das einzige, was mir jetzt einfällt, ich weiß
nicht, ob Twitch sowas hat. Was macht das da eigentlich gerade? Was, was, was, was treibt
der hier eigentlich gerade? Ist mir egal, ich warte einfach bis er fertig ist. Who cares?
Cool. Ach, man kann sich in den Twitch-Einstellungen tatsächlich eine Abo-History anzeigen lassen.
Das ist mir neu. Aber ein weiteres Indiz dafür, dass der Chat halt einfach ist. PC-lustig,
garantiert. Garantiert interessiert sich der Twitch für. Die werden wahrscheinlich das
Mindeste machen, was sie machen müssen, dass sie in Deutschland nicht abgeschaltet werden.
Was ist eigentlich auch Media Vault? Ein Frontend zum verwalten von einem NAS. Oder ein NAS
mit einem Web-Frontend, wo man das einfach drüber verwalten kann. Und da kam jetzt erst
vor einem Monat oder zwei oder so irgendwie eine neue Version raus und ich wollte mir
mal angucken, wie das gerade sich auf Raspberry Pi schlägt, weil ich ja immer den Raspberry
Flame, das ein schlechtes NAS ist. Oder eine schlechte Hardware-Basis für NAS. Was sagt
eigentlich Hacker News heute? Gibt es da irgendwas Spannendes? Übrigens eine der, der retro-optischsten
Retro-Seiten schlechthin. Aber dafür ist es schnell. Nichts Spannendes dabei. Microsoft
calls for a closer look at App-Stores. Ja, ihr eigene App-Store ist ja auch crap. Control
OBS from the Browser. Das ist nicht neu. Das habe ich schon vor einer ganzen Weile mal
verwendet. Es könnte sein, dass das jetzt was Neues ist. Aber das habe ich schon vor
zwei... Okay anscheinend ist das wirklich was ganz was Neues. Aber OBS über ein Browser
bedienen, das habe ich schon vor ein paar Jahren gemacht. Das ist nichts Neues. Aber
vielleicht ist das was gut Nutzbares. Übrigens, wenn ihr richtiger Hacker-Sore sein wollt,
müsst ihr einmal täglich Hacker-News lesen. Das ist euch schon klar, oder? Allerdings
nichts wirklich interessantes dabei heute. Android isn't based on Linux, it's based
on Danger OS. Okay. Dieses Thema umschiffen wir jetzt mal. Warte Installation, sind wir
noch nicht fertig. Ist das jetzt, hat das jetzt eigentlich funktioniert? Oh Leute, ich
glaube die Installation ist fertig. Das ist einfach nur... Ah der rebootet gerade. Der
rebootet gerade. Ich hoffe der ist gleich wieder da. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Der sieht aber schlecht aus. Der ist schon seit zwei Minuten weg. Ich sehe es hier gerade.
Ich vermute, Leute, ich vermute die Open Media Vault Installation hat es kaputt gemacht.
Ich glaube das hat den Raspberry Pi geschrottet, die Installation. Ich gucke mal ob er noch
blinkt. Ich gucke mal ob er noch blinkt. Warte mal kurz. Blinkt er noch? Macht er noch was?
Sieht zumindest so aus. Soll ich mal Ausschalt wieder einschalten? Es kam gerade die Frage
kannst du den Raspberry Pi am Monitor anschließen? Ja könnte ich machen. Da muss ich meine Capture
Card anschließen. Und ich habe mir jetzt nämlich einen HDMI Adapter gekauft für den Raspberry
Pi. Das können wir gleich machen. Wir warten noch mal kurz. Wir warten noch mal eine Minute.
Weil der macht auch was. Ich sehe auch dieses Aktivitätslämpchen ist da gerade wild am
blinken. Vielleicht resize da gerade die Partition oder kein Schimmer was da dran. Wir warten
mal noch ein paar Minuten und dann schließe ich meinen Monitor dran an. Oder schließe
meine Capture Card dran an dann könnt ihr auch gucken. Aber das scheint echt ganz praktisch
zu sein. Lab Interface für OBS. Aber wie gesagt das habe ich vor ein paar Jahren schon
verwendet halt anscheinend nicht das hier. Moin Phoenix. Ehh nichts spannendes dabei
heute. Ich könnte aber schon mal die Capture Card anschließen. Ich schließe schon mal
die Capture Card. Anders schadet ja nichts. Wo habe ich es denn hier? Elgato. Elgato wo
bist du? Ah. Exzellent. Ehh nein das connecten wir nicht zur VM sondern zum Host. So.
Wie hieß das Ding von der Elgato nochmal? Game Capture HD hieß das Ding genau. Schauen
wir mal. Schauen wir mal ob der Raspberry Pi nicht startet. Flow 96 hier. Film ich.
One moment please. Ja du kannst kein Signal detekten weil kein Signal drauf ist. Find
Signals. Ok der Raspberry Pi starten nicht mehr. Ich brauche ein HDMI Kabel. Ich brauche
ein HDMI Kabel. Wo habe ich ein HDMI Kabel? Ist das hier ein HDMI Kabel was man verwenden
kann? HDMI. Ah das sieht nach HDMI aus. Wartet mal. HDMI. Ehh falls ich gleich weg bin habe
ich aus Versehen das Audio Interface rausgezogen. Aber noch bin ich da. Das Kabel liegt da nämlich
ziemlich dazwischen. So. Exzellent. Oh nee. So. So ich habe das HDMI Kabel rausgezogen.
Ich schließe es mal an die Capture Card an. Schauen wir mal was der Raspberry Pi so sagt.
Ich habe mir jetzt ja einen Adapter gekauft. Mikro HDMI auf HDMI. Oder wie die coolen
Leute sagen. HDMI. Ach und du das jetzt? Ach und du das jetzt? Ach und du das jetzt?
Weißt jemand ob ich den Raspberry Pi dazu aus- und einschalte muss das das funktioniert?
Wahrscheinlich, ja?
Wahrscheinlich muss ich das...
Ähm, ich muss übrigens kurz mal mein Headset entwirren, Leute.
So, ich bin wieder da.
Ähm, also anscheinend passiert da nichts.
Okay, ich schalte den Raspberry Pi mal einen aus.
Ich hoffe jetzt, als letztes Mal war ja das HDMI-Kabel kaputt, ne?
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Hab ich's überhaupt beim Input eingeschlossen?
Input, ja, gut.
So, Raspberry Pi ist an.
Okay, Elgato, wo ist das Problem?
Excellent, funktioniert richtig gut.
Top.
Poggers, wahnsinnig, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ist aber jetzt doch egal, wo man das anschließt, oder?
Raspberry Pi 4.
Also, ich hab das jetzt hier an dem, an dem Monitorausgang angeschlossen.
Da.
Das ist HDMI 0, das ist ja auch richtig.
Macht aber nix.
Ja, ich hab grad neu gebootet nach dem Input.
Also, ich hab das jetzt hier an dem, an dem Monitorausgang angeschlossen.
Ja, ich hab grad neu gebootet und hab HDMI angeschlossen.
Also, ich hab jetzt ein Nagel, Niegelnagel neuer Mikro-HDMI auf HDMI-Adapter.
Das HDMI-Kabel geht auch.
Das weiß ich, das war nämlich vorher an der Capture Card dran und das, das geht auch.
Ähm, tja, warum man da jetzt nix sieht, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Macht das nochmal raus und bitte rein.
Ob das was bringt.
Auch nicht.
Warum, warum schaff ich's eigentlich nicht, dem Raspberry Pi ein HDMI-Signal zu entlocken?
Kann doch nicht sein.
Ich war mehr als ein Adapter anschließend und die Capture Card anschließend, kann ich doch auch nicht machen.
Hast du beide HDMI-Ports ausprobiert?
Nee, nee, nee, nur den einen.
Ich probier mal den anderen aus.
Kann ich, schadet ja nix, ne?
Und jetzt tut sich was?
Nö, natürlich nicht.
Warum auch?
Warum sollte sich da auch was tun, ne?
Ja, dann würd ich mal sagen.
Die Installation hat dazu geführt, dass unser Raspberry Pi nicht mehr funktioniert.
HDMI geht auch nicht mehr.
Aber der Raspberry Pi selbst wird ziemlich sicher noch funktionieren.
Äh, ich hab's neu gestartet, ja.
Ja, ich starte jetzt nochmal neu.
Also der Raspberry Pi wird noch funktionieren.
Wenn ich jetzt der SD-Card reinmache und flasche, dann wird's ziemlich sicher funktionieren.
Das Dumme ist nur...
Ich hab jetzt mal wieder...
Das geht nicht an.
Das juckt dir so überhaupt nicht.
HDMI...
...ist ihm vollkommen egal.
Dazu kann man eigentlich nur noch sagen.
Nö, der hat keinen Bock.
Äh, man könnte auch jetzt gar nichts großartig machen.
Das Einzige, was ich machen könnte, ist den Raspberry Pi neu flaschen.
Aber dann hab ich keinen Open Media Vault installiert.
Und ich vermute mal, Open Media Vault hat Probleme mit von SSD zu booten.
Was ziemlich sackt.
Weil was...
Was will ich das mit so einer kacken SD-Karte?
Tja, wisst ihr was?
Dann lassen wir's einfach.
Dann halt nicht, ne?
Was ist denn das hier für ein Kabel?
Wartet mal, was ist das hier für ein Kabel?
Hab ich denn hier für ein HDMI-Kabel rumfliegen?
Ah.
Okay, ich hab noch ein anderes HDMI-Kabel.
Das ist das HDMI-Kabel, was wir das letzte Mal verwendet haben.
Das kann ich auch mal schnell dazwischen stöpseln, ob das dann funktioniert.
Dann gucken wir mal.
Aber wahrscheinlich...
Alter, warum sind HDMI-Kabel immer länger als man sie braucht?
Und wenn man sie länger braucht, sind sie zu kurz.
Sackt.
So, stöpseln wir das nochmal dazwischen.
Macht die Elgato jetzt eigentlich irgendwas?
Ne, hat keinen Bock.
Die will nicht.
So.
Ich stöpsel das Ding jetzt wieder auf HDMI 0.
Verkehr derum gibt's doch bei HDMI nicht, ne?
Im Bikro HDMI, wenn's passt, dann passt's, genau.
Passt. Oder auch nicht.
So, Kabel.
Zack.
Kabel an die Elgato dran.
Und juckt nicht. Ist eben vollkommen egal.
Strom aus.
Strom an.
Ja. Ist eben vollkommen egal.
Ja.
Ja. Richtig.
Undercover.
Das ist aber nur davon, wo die Fehlermeldung kommt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Interface von meiner VM.
Gut. Sehr schön. Raspberry Pi boot nicht mehr.
Kein Bock mehr drauf. Scheiß drauf. Ist mir zu dumm.
Das Ding jetzt noch mal komplett neu flashen
und das noch mal neu installieren, hab ich ehrlich gesagt.
Kein.
Bei.
Ne, also Leute.
Wir können uns das aussuchen.
Es ist ja schon 20.15.
Open Media Vault in einer VM.
Ne, ich probier, dass das nächste Mal eine Raspberry Pi ist.
Wir können jetzt ne SD-Karte nehmen.
Ich hab hier noch genug.
Mikro SD-Karte nehmen, neu flashen.
Können wir machen. Können wir machen.
Doch, einmal neu flashen tun wir, weil
ich wissen will.
Doch, doch, doch. Einmal neu flashen werden wir auf jeden Fall.
Weil ich wissen möchte,
ob der Raspberry Pi überhaupt irgendwie tut
mit der HDMI-Ausgabe.
Das machen wir noch mal.
Wir downloaden mal ein aktuelles Raspbian,
falls wir noch keins haben.
Wir haben bestimmt eins.
Downloaden einfach jetzt mal das alleraktuellste.
Mai 2020.
Light.
Dann brauch ich meinen SD-Karten-Reader.
Da ist er.
Ja, SD-Karte neu.
Save, ja, ja.
Speicher mal.
Das ist 32-Bit, ja, ist okay.
Ist doch okay.
Raspbian ist 32-Bit.
Es gibt ne Beta-Version, glaub, mit 64-Bit.
Aber das meint, es ist okay, dass es 32-Bit ist.
So, dann machen wir den SD-Karten-Reader rein.
SD-Karten-Reader rein.
Und so.
Poggers.
Dann flashen wir das Ganze mal.
Speicher.
So ein ADME-Splitter fällt mir jetzt keiner ein.
Select Target.
Ist gar nicht dran.
Doch.
Hä?
Flash from File.
Max Download Buster.
Ach so, der denkt, es ist zu groß.
Nee, nee, nee, ist schon okay.
64G ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Zack, Flash.
Bam, in your face.
Auf G, das wird geflasht.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob die Grafik-Ausgabe wenigstens funktioniert.
Dann mach ich die SSD ab.
Und wir booten von MicroSD-Karte.
Ja, das ist aber ganz schön kacke.
Es gibt doch ein fertig...
Nee, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Den 5er gibt es nicht mehr als fertiges Image.
Weil die sagen, man soll einen Raspian installieren und dann das Installer-Skript laufen lassen.
Schreiben sie zumindest hier.
Ja, gibt es nicht mehr, gibt kein fertiges Image.
Für 4er, fürs 4er gab es glaube ich ein fertiges Image.
Aber auch nur von Ultralight.
Validieren.
Ja, ich habe es nicht mehr.
Ich habe es nicht mehr.
Validieren.
Exzellent.
Komm mal her, sieht man übrigens Elektron-Gedöns.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, dass wir mal 2020 ein Programm zum Kopieren, zum DD-Frontend in Elektron haben.
Ja, was gibt Frontend für DD?
I only, ja, habe ich, das funktioniert.
Das verwende ich gerade schon.
Guck mal, ich glaube, da habe ich sogar noch ein paar Bilder hier irgendwo, wenn ich in meinem Desktop etwas finde.
Revealed.
Nein.
Irgendwo hier hatte ich da ein paar Bilder vom aktuellen NAS.
Seht ihr es irgendwo?
Ich sehe es nicht.
Server, hier, guck mal da.
Das ist low budget, mein low budget NAS-Bild.
Genau, ja, das hat funktioniert.
Das hat den billigsten, der Ziel war ja, das günstigste 10G-NAS überhaupt zu bauen.
Das hat einen Wechselrahmen, der billigste, den es gibt.
Hotswapfähigste, billigste, Hotswapfähigste Rahmen, den es gibt.
So viele USB-Anschlüsse, wie irgendwie geht.
Hier ist die 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte drin.
Man sieht, die gehört eigentlich nicht auf die Seite.
Die habe ich mit so einer PCI-Express-Verlängerung da drüben hin gebaut,
weil hier war das zu klein wegen dem Laufwerks-Schacht.
Ja, gibt es da vorne ein Video?
Nö, gibt kein Video von Aldi Talk, null.
Ich empfehle aber keinem, das nachzubauen,
weil das wirklich nur versucht war, wie man das günstige, der günstigen 10G-NAS bauen kann.
Also ein bisschen Geld mehr bringt einiges an Qualität mehr.
Okay, wir haben geflasht.
Ich schiebe das mal in den Raspberry Pi rein und gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert jetzt.
Gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Der Raspberry Pi sollte jetzt ja starten mit der SD-Karte drin.
Ach nee, haha, wichtig, ich wollte schon was vergessen.
Schon einen neuen Outro heute gesehen.
Ja, hat mir der Sebaro vorhin gezeigt.
Macht einen richtig guten Eindruck.
Was mir an dem Outro heute nicht gefällt, ist, dass er halt so einen kacken Formfaktor hat.
Also der passt jetzt kein richtiges Gehäuse rein.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie das nicht einfach ordentlich gebaut haben.
Mount, also wir mounten uns jetzt mal die SD-Karte.
Und was man immer machen muss, wenn man einen Raspberry Pi neu hat, Touch SSH.
Sonst schaltet er kein SSH ein und das ist in der Tat ziemlich doof.
Übrigens hätte ich mal unmounten sollen.
Unmount.
Sync.
Sehr gut.
Case 3D, das ist doch für'n Arsch.
Ich will doch kein Case 3D Druck.
Erstens druckt das gefüllte Jahre und ist zwar mit einem ordentlichen Gehäuse qualitativ überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen.
Geschweige denn, dass dort auch keine Hotswap-Rahmen oder sonst was reinpassen.
Was macht Sync?
Das schreibt alle Buffer von den Geräten.
Es sorgt dafür, dass alles, was in irgendeinem Buffer drin ist, auch wirklich auf ein Gerät geschrieben wird.
So, mal gucken, ob der jetzt bootet damit.
Schauen wir mal.
Und mal gucken, ob's HDMI angeht.
Warum macht man immer die SD-Karte falsch rum rein?
Immer.
Ah.
Excellent.
Oder einschalten.
Macht das was?
Ah.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Oder einschalten. Macht das was?
Muss man auf dem Raspberry Pi 4 irgendwas machen, dass HDMI funktioniert?
Weil der bootet und alles wunderbar.
Die SD-Karte ist angegangen, aber der HDMI-Ausgang funktioniert nicht.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Der funktioniert.
Anderen Stellen haben wir auch schon probiert.
Gleich ist er wieder da.
Da ist er. Guck. Fertig.
Da ist er.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Weg damit.
Yes.
Schau mal, X-Render.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich hab da glaube ich nichts installiert, aber probieren wir mal.
Kann man X-Render überhaupt gescheit über SSH verwenden?
Was muss man dafür überhaupt installieren?
Das ist sehr merkwürdig.
Irgendwas an meinen Settings kaputt vielleicht.
Input Device, PC.
Macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
So, Update.
Leute, ich guck mal, dass das HDMI-Kabel auch richtig drin ist im Raspberry Pi.
Vielleicht ist das Gehäuse ja zu fett.
Das wäre ziemlich kacke.
Kann schon mal updaten. Muss er eh machen.
Ja, das ist er.
Ach, das mach ich.
Also, das Gehäuse hatte ein bisschen Plastik, was da übersteht.
Vielleicht passt der Stecker da nicht richtig rein.
Ich hab schon alle Kabel ausprobiert.
Also wir haben es das letzte Mal herausgefunden, dass das HDMI-Kabel im Arsch war.
Aber vielleicht passt auch der Stecker nicht richtig rein.
Dann muss ich den Raspberry Pi jetzt mal ausbauen aus dem Gehäuse.
Aber dann fällt das ganze Gehäuse auseinander, weil das so ein billiges, aufeinander liegendes Kackehäuse ist.
Erst mal updaten lassen.
Was hältst du von den GPU-Features für WSL2?
Was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass es für AI-Geschichten irgendwie jetzt GPU-Acceleration gibt.
Ja, ist mir eigentlich wurscht.
Ich baue den Raspberry Pi jetzt aus.
Sobald das Update fertig ist, schraube ich das mal kurz aus dem Gehäuse raus.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das so hinpasst.
Vielleicht kann ich ihn einfach nur ein Stückchen hochheben, muss ihn nicht komplett rausschrauben.
Mal gucken.
Erst mal warten, bis er fertig geupdatet hat.
Ich unterschätze das immer wie Lamson und Raspberry Pi auf einer microSD-Karte updatet.
Und es ist eine schnelle microSD-Karte.
Das ist eine Samsung 64G, Samsung Endurance Blob, sonst was.
Das ist quasi eine SSD, eine microSD.
Oh, ich habe einen Schluck auf. Schau wieder.
360 NoScope, aber wie hier?
Oh, er ist fertig.
Power off.
Okay, ich schraube es jetzt echt aus dem Gehäuse raus. Ich glaube es nicht.
Zum Glück habe ich hier ein richtig schickes Vera-Schraubendreher-Set.
Für Fein-Mechanik-Schraubendreher-Set.
Damit kann man das wunderbar machen.
Kann man auch mit jedem anderen Schraubendreher machen.
Oder Schraubenzieher, wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
So, Raspberry Pi hat sich beendet.
Mal hier Kabels raus machen.
Dann schraube ich das Ding mal auf. Aber nur, dass auch in jedem Fall das HDMI-Kabel richtig drin ist.
Es könnte sein, dass es wirklich daran liegt.
Schrauben wir mal ab.
Mal gucken.
Chat und ich mache euch in der Zwischenzeit. Das dauert jetzt zwei Minuten, das geht schnell.
Ich mache euch mal das ASCII-Quarium an, dass ihr was zu gucken habt.
Während der Max Schrauber-Man macht.
Schraube raus. Schraube raus. Schraube raus.
Reicht das schon?
Ah, das könnte fast... Nee, reicht nicht.
Ich muss alle Schrauben raus machen.
Okay, nächste Schraube. Zack, Schraube raus.
Schraube raus.
So.
Eine noch.
Oh, das Gehäuse fällt komplett auseinander schon.
Das ist richtig schlecht, das China-Case.
Jetzt habe ich aber auch keinen Lüfter mehr und sowas.
Oh Gott, das ganze Gehäuse fällt auseinander.
Hier.
Hört ihr es?
Kack-China-Gehäuse, ey.
Lull.
Ja, ich habe das Gehäuse vor mir liegen.
Kack-China-Gehäuse, Alter.
Boah, was ein Fummelkram.
Ja, das wollte ich mir auch holen, das Argon One.
So, schließen wir mal wieder an.
Mal gucken, ob jetzt die Ausgabe funktioniert.
So.
Also, Netzwerk rein.
Netzwerk rein.
HDMI rein.
Ah, das war nicht richtig drinne.
Wegen diesem dummen Drecksgehäuse.
Jetzt hat es richtig geklackst beim Reinschieben.
Passt mal auf, jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich.
Und?
Aha!
Kack-Waite?
Das sind wir.
Okay, das Gehäuse ist crap.
Richtiges Drecksgehäuse.
Richtiger Müll, Alter, richtiger Müll.
Richtig räudig.
Gut, jetzt wissen wir übrigens auch, dass die grafische Ausgabe funktioniert.
Dann müssen wir jetzt nochmal den Installer laufen lassen.
Bleibt uns ja nichts anderes übrig.
Habe ich zwar keinen großartigen Bock drauf, aber wir müssen nochmal den Installer laufen lassen.
Haben wir gemacht, haben wir gemacht, was sollten wir löschen?
Etc, System, wir machen das jetzt im schnellen Durchgang, System D, Network, was dann, Default, 99.
Okay, so, W, W.
Oh ja, Leak, Leute, ganz, ganz viel Leak wieder.
W, Get, sudo bash.
Okay, Installer machen wir nochmal.
Ich muss mal kurz das Gehäuse von meinem Schreibtisch aufräumen.
Das liegt jetzt, hier liegen jetzt irgendwie 15 Teile rum von so einem Kack-China-Gehäuse.
Weg, am besten gleich in Müll.
Richtiges Gefummel.
Gachi-Bass.
Ein.
Ein Vorteil hat das ja, dass ich so viel Kram bei AliExpress bestelle, so viel Elektronik-Kleinkram.
Ich habe jetzt Kästchen in allen nur erdenklichen Größen und Formen.
Für alles mögliche.
Also wenn ich mal ein Kästchen brauche, ich habe auf jeden Fall eins.
Die meisten könnte ich aber mal wegschmeißen.
Hier stapeln sich die AliExpress Kartons.
Keksform, ich habe einen 3D, ich habe einen 3D Druck vom Max FPS Keks.
Ich habe beim Thema Kekse.
Ja, genau, choose my name, eating ASMR ist angesagt.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was ich mir letzten Tage wieder installiert habe?
Ok, anscheinend ist das nur für einen User installiert.
Ich habe mir Battlefield 3 wieder installiert.
Excellent, vielleicht spielen wir das mal irgendwann morgen im Stream oder so.
Dann werde ich eine Runde Battlefield.
Das ist der Vierer.
Das ist der Vierer mit 4GB.
Kannst du mein Bild zeigen?
Nö, kann ich nicht.
Ist nicht parat.
Gut, der installiert jetzt mit der 10 Minuten wahrscheinlich oder 5 Minuten.
Ging auch relativ schnell.
Excellent.
Der Twitch Chat ist jetzt Inception.
Unten rechts ist der Chat, den man vorher im Chat hier sieht.
Marius, könntest du mal ein Video über Passwortmanager machen?
Stimmt.
Du kannst einfach Key Pass verwenden und gut ist.
Oder Bitworn, wenn du was brauchst, was immer online ist.
Also was du auch einfach sünden kannst übers Internet oder so, wenn man das will.
So, Chat, ich lasse euch mal kurz mit dem Chat allein.
Ich gehe mal ganz schnell aufs Klo.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, wieder da.
Leute, soll ich mal sagen, hier drinnen ist übertrieben warm.
Mit zwei Rechnern an.
Tür zu und ich hocke hier drinnen.
Das ist wirklich massig warm.
Der Raspberry Pi wärmt wahrscheinlich den Raum auf.
Der Pi 4 ist so hot.
Was sagt der Installer hier eigentlich?
Der sagt, er macht Dinge, was auch immer für Dinge.
Kack FPS, ja warte, genau so sieht es aus.
Vielleicht mache ich auch wirklich ein Video über Passwortmanager.
Ich weiß, dass ich das schon vor einer ganzen Weile gesagt habe, dass ich das machen will.
Oder dass ich da nicht abgeneigt bin, das zu machen.
Ups, jetzt habe ich den Chat zugemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel das interessiert.
Ich weiß, dass hier einige dabei sind, die es interessieren.
Aber so global gesehen auf YouTube ist das, denke ich mal, die, gibt es nicht viele, die das interessiert.
Habe ich schon gesehen?
Macht einen richtig guten Eindruck.
Leider ist der Formfaktor des Boards halt so dumm und passt in kein Gehäuse.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie das nicht einfach als Mikro ATX oder irgendwas Normales gebaut haben.
Warum eigentlich?
Warum haben die das Board nicht als irgendwas ganz Normales gebaut?
Um Geld mit Cases zu verdienen.
Ja, vielleicht.
Aber das offizielle Case ist so dermaßen hässlich.
Und auch unnützig, man kann damit gar nichts anfangen.
Dein Channel wird von YouTube doch eh als tot angesehen.
Nur Leute aus deinem Stream werden das mal überschauen.
Sobald ich ein Video hochlade, habe ich nach ein paar Tagen 30.000 plus Views.
Wenn ich ein ordentliches Video hochlade.
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt nicht wahnsinnig präsent im aktuellen YouTube Algorithmus.
Ja, das ist klar, denn ich lade ja nichts hoch.
Aber wenn ich was hochlade, kriegen das schon die meisten zu Gesicht.
Du sagst wenigstens, dass VPN nicht gleich anonym ist.
Wurde ja auch mal Zeit, dass man sich der Sache annimmt.
Express VPN.
Nord VPN.
Die haben ja alle möglichen Channels mittlerweile übernommen, was VPN Werbung angeht.
Der Eiskäu, der hat sogar die Glocke aktiviert.
Oh, das ist Big Brain.
Also schon hier.
Huge Brain ist das.
Die Glocke aktiviert.
Ja, aber ein eigenes Case ist doch doof, da kriegst du gar keinen Wechselrahmen rein.
Kein Hotswap-fähigen Wechselrahmen und sonst was.
Gerade wenn man das Ding für nass verwenden will, ist das doch gerade dann gut.
Oder gerade doof mit dem Gehäuse.
Du benutzt i3-gaps mit i3-status-bar.
Ich verwende i3-gaps mit i3-status-rust, nennt sich das.
Da gibt es einen Stream von, ja.
Zum Programme öffnen verwende ich rofi.
Das da.
Das, so wenn ich so Programme starten.
Oh, Klimaanlage ist so angenehm, ne?
Ich hab jetzt die Klimaanlage angemacht schon.
Auch instant hier fast ne ordentliche Temperatur wieder drin, ne?
Ein excellent Beam.
Hast du nen Vorschlag?
So, was macht die Installation?
Oh, fertig.
Hat das jetzt neu gestartet?
Ne, noch nicht.
Noch nicht.
Aber der wird sich gleich neu starten.
Warum krieg ich Battlefield 3 nicht an?
Oh.
Den Mist hab ich noch installiert, ja.
Ach ne, das sind die Settings.
Ich spiel pega.
Jetzt neu starten?
Ne, immer noch nicht.
Auch nicht.
Chat, ich blende euch mal kurz aus.
Nicht, nicht Chat.
Muss euch mal kurz ausblenden.
Und Origin starten.
Gucken warum der mein Battlefield nicht anzeigt.
So, mal gucken warum der mein Battlefield nicht anzeigt.
Battlefield 3 ist doch da.
Ja.
Guck mal.
Doch da.
Das Leben ist ein Spiel und Informatikor ist bereit es zu spielen.
Aha.
Alles klar.
Das liegt an einer guten Windows-Suche.
Ja anscheinend.
Du findest nicht.
Okay, die Logik erschließt sich mir nicht.
Jetzt neu starten?
Ne, der ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Schauen wir doch gerade mal.
Battlefield 3 Server.
Was da gerade so am Start ist.
Ich hab nämlich gestern und vorgestern schon ein bisschen gespielt.
Und es gab immer noch ganz gut besuchte Server.
Dazu muss man allerdings sagen, es gibt es jetzt ja auch neuerdings auf Steam.
Und es sind einige Noobs am Start.
Also ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es tatsächlich nochmal Weihnachtsnoobs in Battlefield 3 gibt.
Mir ist das richtig voll.
Ob ranked ist oder nicht ist mir vollkommen wurscht.
Rush will ich haben.
Ja.
Es gibt sogar wieder halbwegs vollen 16 vs. 16 Server.
Rush Classics.
Oh, haben wir es geschafft.
Rebootet er jetzt?
Er jetzt rebootet?
Was sagt er hier?
IP Address may change and could lose connection.
Okay, jetzt hat er neu gestartet.
Jetzt hat er neu gestartet.
Ich guck mal in meinem DHCP, dass ich...
Okay, der hat wirklich eine neue IP gekriegt.
Vielleicht hat das vorhin auch funktioniert und das Ding hat einfach die IP gewechselt.
Und ich hab's nicht gesehen, weil ich zu pepega war, das zu sehen.
Man weiß ja nie, ne?
Okay, gucken wir mal. 1, 2, 1, 6, 8, 2, 1, 2, 9.
Open Media Vault.
Da ist es doch.
Open Media Vault Default Name.
Was ist das Default vom Admin?
Open Media Vault.
Ja, da sind wir.
Funktioniert.
So, die Oberfläche sieht immer noch ein bisschen eklig aus.
Also ich finde nicht, dass die Oberfläche jetzt wahnsinnig for usability strotzt.
Die sieht noch genauso aus wie das letzte Mal.
Was können wir hier sonst machen?
Wo kann ich jetzt...
Ich schließe jetzt mal die SSD an.
So hell.
Ja, ja.
Kann man das umstellen?
Hat das einen Dark Steam?
Hat das irgendwo einen Dark Steam?
Kann man das umstellen?
General.
Du hast doch Darkreader.
Na, hier in der VM nicht.
Anscheinend, das ist kein Dark Steam.
Tja.
Da müssen wir uns jetzt noch ein bisschen umstellen.
So, ich schließe jetzt mal die SSD an und wir gucken, wie man die hier ordentlich konfigurieren
kann über das Web-Enterface.
SSD, komm her.
SSD ist dran.
Wie funktioniert das?
Disks.
SDA, da ist es.
Sandisk.
Wipe.
Yes.
Quick.
Das nehme ich mal platt, da ist ja eh nichts wirklich wildes drauf, was wir brauchen auf
der SSD.
Kann Open Media World Speicher wie Samba für Windows bereitstellen?
Ja.
Das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
So, erstmal die SSD.
Also was ich jetzt ausprobieren will, ob sich das eignet auch, also ich verschlüssel jetzt
die SSD, irgendwie gucken, wie das Open Media World, ich glaube, ZFS geht nur über Plugins.
Aber wir werden es jetzt sehen.
Früher ging es nur über Plugins.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay, wie geht das jetzt hier weiter?
Edit?
Nee.
Create.
Select.
Okay, die SSD.
X4.
Ja, da machen wir X4.
Okay.
Label.
Cute Chat.
Do you really want format this device?
Yes.
Okay, Chat, weil ihr es seid.
Dark Reader Addon.
Weil ihr es seid.
Moment, ist das Firefox oder ist das Chrome?
Das ist Firefox.
Ah, ich hasse Sachen, die ausklappen, wenn man schneller aimt auf der Webseite, als es
ausklappt.
Kennt ihr das?
Webseiten, die nachladen und ihr habt schon richtig geaimt und verklickt euch dann.
Wow.
Monkeys.
Was geht mit dem hier ab?
Das verwirrt den normalen User aber auf jeden Fall, wenn so komische unescapte, wahrscheinlich
die Color Codes oder so im Webinterface ankommen.
9G Stealth 90.
Das verwirrt den normalen User.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das sind Color Codes für die Konsole.
Aber, dass es im Webinterface nicht gefiltert wird, ist fail.
Gut.
Also.
Ach nee.
Wir müssen es wieder löschen.
Ich wollte es ja vorher verschlüsseln.
Nee, wir machen zwei Sachen.
Wir machen einmal einen Samba.
Wir machen einmal einen Samba-Server und gucken, wie schnell das ist unverschlüsselt.
Vorher schauen wir mal, wie schnell die SSD an sich ist.
Was wird gemacht?
Nass im Raid?
Nee, nur SSD.
Einfach mal gucken, ob sich der Raspberry Pi dafür grundsätzlich eignet, weil ich
flame den immer, dass der sich dafür nicht eignet.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, wir werden es auch gleich sehen, dass er sich nicht für
ein halbwegs ordentliches Nass eignet.
Aber gucken wir mal.
So.
Also.
Wir machen mal ein TD.
Und wir können auch noch was anderes machen.
Wir können einfach die Noob-Variante machen.
Installieren wir mal PV.
Das ist der Vierer.
Vierer mit 4 GB.
So.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, wo das Ganze gemountet ist.
Wo sieht man bei Open Media Vault, wo was gemountet ist?
Wo ist mein SDA1?
Ach, man muss ja auf Einklicken klicken.
Ah, das macht er.
Ok.
Ich hätte gedacht, das macht er irgendwo sonst wo hin.
Ich habe auf Mount geklickt.
Juckt ihn aber nicht, ja.
Ah.
Da.
Ok.
Cut.
Def.
Zero.
Nicht Cut.
Äh.
Moment.
Doch.
Kann man das nicht schöner machen?
Nach PV.
Blub.
Gucken wir mal, wie schnell die SDRs kommen.
Ach nee, andersherum.
Andersherum und dann umleiten.
Worum war das?
Genau.
So, das ist nicht die beste SSD.
Aber so ungefähr, so ungefähr einen, also Gigabit Netzwerk sollten wir ungefähr ausgelastet
bekommen.
So über den Daumen gepilet, na.
Ich meine, die SSD ist halt low budget, also ungefähr Gigabit sollten wir hinkriegen.
PV zeigt dir an, was er gerade kopiert, wie viel schnell.
Also, PV liest dahin, liest da raus und zeigt dir an, wie schnell er liest.
Und er liest so schnell, wie er hier es auf die Platte schreiben kann.
So.
Gut.
Das zeigt dir dann quasi an, wie schnell er ist.
Das geht mit DD auch.
Also, man kann das mit DD, kann man das genauso machen.
Aber ich finde es mit PV ist die Ausgabe schöner.
So, dann, ähm, wissen wir jetzt, dass das funktioniert und die SSD halbwegs schnell
ist.
Dann gucken wir mal, wie man da jetzt einen Samba-Server anlegen kann.
SMB, CIFS.
Enable.
Oh, das ist ja Leute, Dark Reader macht's kaputt.
Apply.
Yes.
Also, wir haben so eine, das finde ich ganz gut, wir haben so eine halbwegs failsafe Geschichte
eingebaut.
Also sprich, es aktiviert nicht automatisch, nur weil du es auf aktiviert setzt, sondern
du musst es wirklich noch applyn.
Also, falls dir der Strom dann abkackt oder irgendwas ist, dann ist es auch wieder in
einem Zustand, wo es, das finde ich ganz zinnig.
Macht der da eigentlich im Hintergrund gerade?
Leute, ich muss den Dark Reader ausschalten, der macht die Webseite kaputt.
Guckt, seht ihr das?
Da sehe ich den Enable-Knopf nicht.
Ah, es blendet, ja ich sehe es schon.
Alles gut, passt, sonst was, shares, add, select, share, add, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich
hier mache.
Aja ja, heißt der, select device, Qt chat, device, pass, aja ja, permissions, everyone,
read write, save, exellent.
Static, ja, alles gut, save, apply, yes, was, man könnte Dark Reader auf Static stellen,
probier mal aus.
Stellt man Dark Reader auf Static?
Ich sehe hier nichts, was man da großartig machen kann, ah hier, oh, nein, ja, da geht
es wenigstens halbwegs.
So, schauen wir mal, ob das schon funktioniert, 1, 2, 1, 2, 2, 1, 2, 9, noch kein Samba an,
oder doch?
Mal Windows ping, igitt, ja, sollte jetzt nicht der Samba-Server aufgehen?
It's enabled, nmap, ah haben wir nicht, haben wir noch kein, netstat, slash aja ja, sollte
denn das nicht dann anbieten, service sollte eigentlich aktiviert sein, habe ich hier oben
gemacht, sieht man jetzt bloß nicht, weil der Dark Reader im Weg ist, guck da, enabled,
cannot access, ja, so einfach scheint das schon mal nicht zu sein, yes, mach mal, guck
mal, ob das Samba Zeug läuft, nee, anscheinend nicht, Samba aktiviert, du kannst doch Samba
gar nicht deaktivieren in Windows, oder, kannst du Samba kleine Windows deaktivieren, nee,
zumindest muss man das aktiv machen, ja, aber habe ich garantiert nicht deaktiviert.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was ist denn das, 3, 8, 9, 4, 4, 5, ah da ist es doch, jetzt ist
es an, jetzt ist es an, ja guck, jetzt funktioniert es nämlich auch, aja ja, alles klar, so jetzt
kopieren wir da mal was drauf, wir brauchen was größeres, Download, ja, Windows ISO,
Windows ISO kopieren wir da jetzt drauf, aah, aah, das ist nicht so der Wahnsinn, Samba
ist halt kaum Multithreaded, aah, aah ja, man kann also, unencrypted kann man mit leben,
ich meine Gigabit ist, ist zu zwei Dritteln ausgelastet, ja, zu zwei Dritteln ungefähr
ist Gigabit ausgelastet, das geht, ich glaube da können die meisten mit leben, aber ich
wette mit euch, wenn wir Verschlüsselung einschalten wird das richtig eklig werden,
schauen wir mal gleich, so fertig, kopiert, exzellent, SMB Status, SMB Status, Encryption,
scheint nicht an, für NAS lieber ein Odroid C4, für NAS, ja die Odroid Dinger sind gut,
die Dinger sind auch ziemlich nice, die Dinger sind auch ziemlich nice, weil da kann man
die Festplatte gleich reinstöpseln, die kann ich echt nur empfehlen, wenn ein Low Budget
NAS haben will, was Gigabit Saturated, dann sind die echt gut, so, also nicht, ja ja,
es ist da, also dann ist es auch noch schneller, ich will aber keine Samba Verschlüsselung,
Samba Encryption haben, ich will jetzt auch Filesystem Ebene haben, also sprich ich muss
das ganze jetzt nochmal unmounten, also erstmal den Share löschen, erstmal den Share löschen,
dann Apply, alles gut, kann man da mit 4K Files im Network Stream, ja, ja, ja, das sollte
ohne Probleme reichen, ich meine was hat denn so eine Blu-Ray 40, 50 MBit, das reicht dicke,
du kannst für Samba zum Teil Multithreading aktivieren, das macht es glaube ich sogar
standardmäßig schon, aber das ganze IO und im Kern ist Samba glaube ich immer noch Single
Threaded, das kann bisschen Async, IO und sowas machen, aber im Kern ist Samba glaube
ich pro Connection, pro Transfer Single Threaded, du kannst mehrere, wenn du mehrere Netzwerke
Interfaces hast, kannst du quasi mehrere Connections irgendwie aufmachen zum Samba, wenn es klein
und Samba unterstützt, ok also Disc, die Disc müssen wir nochmal löschen, Wipe, Disc,
Disc Wipen, Quick und dann Hardware Encryption drauf, aber wahrscheinlich weil es noch gemountet
ist, das ist halt doof, dass es das nicht für mich anmountet, dass es zumindest jetzt
mal einen Dialog anbieten und sagt, hey Alter das ist noch gemountet, willst du nicht gleich
anmounten, äh warum kann ich das nicht anmounten, hat da irgendeine glorreiche Idee warum ich
es nicht anmounten kann, kann ich es nicht anmounten, mein Fileshare ist weg, ok wir
machen Samba auch wieder aus, ähm jaja Apple Eye, mit was hast du die SSDs verbunden mit
so einem USB 3 auf SATA Adapter, was anderes kriegst du ja nicht dran, was auch wieder
für den neuen Odroid spricht, da sind zwei SATA Ports drauf, eine M2 auf der Unterseite
und zwei mal 2,5G Ethernet Schnittstellen, also da kannst du nix sagen, nur der Formfaktor
ist halt doof, bei dem Teil, nur der Formfaktor ist doof, das passt halt in kein ordentliches
Gehäuse rein, aber von der Hardware viel viel besser, gar nicht mal so viel teuer, doppelt
so teuer, wenn man sich denkt man braucht einen Raspberry Pi 4 mit 4GB kostet was 45
Euro oder so, so guckt euch mal wie teuer das ist, das ist gar kein so großer Unterschied
mehr, kost doppelt ist aber viel viel viel viel schneller und viel mehr Schnittstellen
und alles, also das lohnt sich in dem Fall sogar, so kann ich jetzt unmounten, darf ich
meine Disk jetzt unmounten, Moment, Fall Distance, warum, was du musst noch den Scherf, ah das
hat er für mich angelegt, ok verstehe, das habe ich ihm auch gesagt, dass er das anlegen
soll, was in der Zeit so passiert, der Raspberry war kaputt, wir mussten das ganze nochmal
neu machen, das 3 und 4 fach Applian oben ist aber auf Dauer schon nervig, Cap'n Peng
sagt es gibt eine extra Platine zum SSDs anstöpseln, ja aber unter der Haube ist es nach wie vor
USB, der Raspberry hat ja nichts anderes, um Sachen anzuschließen, das Netzwerk hing
ja lange Zeit, ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt ist, aber wahrscheinlich ist es immer noch
auch über USB dran, so kann ich den ganzen Kram jetzt unmounten und löschen, darf ich
das jetzt, ja sehr schön, warum braucht der für den unmount so lange, ich meine den unmount
dauert 20 Millisekunden und wenn es hochkommt, was macht der da so lang, so und jetzt kann
ich die Disk endlich wippen, nochmal Applian, Alter was willst du von mir, gehen wir nicht
auf den Sack, was soll ich da alles, warum soll ich da 50 Milliarden fach Applian, ist
geweibt auch ohne zu Applian, jetzt können wir Applian, was will das eigentlich von mir,
ich hab doch gar nichts gemacht, ich soll trotzdem Applian, warum klicke ich nie auf
Applian, wenn ich dann da nochmal auf Applian drücken muss, also was ich kenne von Mikrotik
Routern zum Beispiel, da hast du hier oben so einen Schloss, wenn du das anmachst, dann
setzt der alles was du im Webinterface anklickst auch direkt, aber er schreibt es nicht auf
den Flash, das heißt wenn du dann rebootest hast du wieder eine funktionsfähige Konfig,
das ist zum ausprobieren ganz gut, aber den Sinn hier von diesem Dauer Applian sehe ich
jetzt nicht, ok jetzt probieren wir das ganze mal für Schlüssel zu machen, jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt wo man das macht, wo macht man hier, wo macht man hier Lux Verschlüsselung,
wo macht man hier Festplattenverschlüsselung, wo macht man hier Festplattenverschlüsselung,
ist das ein Plugin, neue Updates checken, Orphe Encryption Disk, der Network Schienobi, ne
Open Media von Lux Encryption, da braucht man ein Plugin für, warum ist denn sowas nicht
Default, ok Borg Backup ist dabei, ist schon mal nice, aber Encryption ich meine das ist
Basic Nass Funktionalität überhaupt, ok installieren wir das, also ich sehe nach wie
vor für mich den Sinn von so nem GUI noch nicht, ich hätte das wahrscheinlich von Hand
alle schon 20bar gemacht, aber es ist ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht für mich gedacht, sondern es soll
einfach einstiegsfreundlich sein, so können wir das jetzt machen, Encryption, ah da sind
wir, create, select device, so das da, wir machen mal nen Crypt Setup Benchmark aufm
Raspberry Pi und gucken mal welches Verschlüsselungsverfahren am schnellsten ist und das nehmen wir dann,
es dauert ne Minute oder ne halbe Minute, es geht relativ schnell, also je nach Hardware
kann das auch sehr unterschiedlich aussehen, zum Beispiel auf aktueller Intel Hardware
mit IES Verschlüsselung, IES in Hardware ist das sau schnell, wollt ihr mal den Unterschied
von Crypt Setup sehen, von dem Raspberry Pi zu meinem Desktop, wohlgemerkt Desktop in
der VM, ich weiß nicht ob man IES NI in der VM überhaupt machen kann, also das ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich alles rein CPU mäßig ohne Hardware Encryption der CPU, guck mal, leichter
Unterschiede, leichter Unterschiede, kaum, kaum, kaum Unterschiede, ja gut, es ist halt
einfach 1000 mal, ne reicht noch nicht, 3000 mal schneller, 3000% schneller, was hältst
du davon, Full Gaming PC, das können wir uns mal angucken wenn du willst, zeig mal her,
und dass wir nicht kopieren gerade, was hältst, ey ich darf nicht kopieren, ich darf nicht
mal copypasten, feelsbadman, darf ich hier copypasten vielleicht, ah hier darf ich copypasten,
alles klar, gut, also was halte ich davon, zeig mal her, wahrscheinlich nix, kann ich
hier gleich sagen, wahrscheinlich nix, aber gucken wir uns das mal an, bei den Franzosen,
wer sind denn die Franzosen, Bons, Bonsplants, alles klar, Kelmer ja wahrscheinlich ist
mein CPU besser, also geht dieser Fertig PC schon, blablabla, also 665 Euro, was gibt
es denn, komisches Gehäuse, was mir nix sagt, keine Ahnung ob das was taugt, das Netzteil
ist ganz gut, Board, CPU ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn, Lüfter könnte es auch ein
Gehäuse sein, 16G ist ok, 480G ist auch ok, 1660 super ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn,
ich glaube das geht besser für den Preis, ich glaube das geht besser für den Preis,
guck mal doch mal was Hardware Rat aktuell so für Ryzen CPUs hat, der ist ja da ganz
gut was Preis-Leistung angeht, guck mal mal, Gaming, der hat kein normales Gaming mehr,
der hat nur RGB Gaming, hättest du Interesse an einem Stream für sowas, hä wie, was meinste,
ach so, was soll ich denn machen im Stream dann, so ein PC Zusammenbau nicht, wie hat
der immer noch Ryzen, Moment, ah hier, nee, Moment, so ungefähr ähnliche Preis, so der
ist deutlich günstiger, der, der kostet ungefähr das gleiche und der kostet ein bisschen mehr
und der kostet ein bisschen weniger, ok was hat denn der da so drinnen, das sieht relativ,
hier mit der Nvidia Karte sieht relativ ähnlich aus, was hat denn der Ryzen 1600 ok, das ist
ja noch ganz alter, also in anbetracht der Tatsache, dass es da bei Hardware Rat auch
nicht viel bessere Sachen gibt, Preis-Leistungs-mäßig, würde ich sagen so schlecht, so schlecht sieht
das jetzt gar nicht mal aus, ist halt immer die Frage, wie es zusammengebaut ist und
was da sonst noch so drin ist, chat was sagt ihr, ich kenn mich ja nicht so gut aus was
Desktop-PCs angeht, also liest sich halbwegs ok oder, ich denke man kriegt es ein bisschen
günstiger hin, ich denke man kriegt es ein bisschen günstiger hin, aber nachdem es bei
Hardware Rat auch nicht so viel besser ist, das Case ist halt hässlich, ja das stimmt,
also der Chat meint für ein Fertig-PC ganz ok, 600 Watt Netzteil ist viel zu viel, ja
aber gut das macht den Preis jetzt auch nicht großartig fett, also man kann es kaufen denke
ich, aber wie gesagt ich würde es mir nicht kaufen, also aus dem Grund, ich kenne mich
zwar nicht mit Desktop-Systemen gut aus, aber wenn ich mir einen neuen PC kaufe, dann kenne
ich mich immer kurzzeitig mit Desktop-Systemen gut aus und ich baue mir den Kram immer selber,
und so schwierig ist es gar nicht, ja Basti das steht jetzt aber nicht zur Debatte wer
mehr für sein PC ausgibt, also gehen wir mal zurück zu, Session expired ok, Admin, Open
Media Vault, Encryption, also wir wollten eine verschlüsselte Platte anlegen, Create,
das da, das ist das beste ja, hat man auch in der Geschwindigkeit gesehen, guck da, passt,
äh das da, ist wahrscheinlich das default oder, was auch immer, steht nicht da, so
label ist mir wurscht, passphrase 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6, Create, yes, das Web Interface
ist langsam, was soll ich denn jetzt applyen, was, was will das von mir mit dem applyen,
das geht mir auf den Sack, aber massiv, warum muss ich laufen applyen, der hat das doch
eh schon gemacht, der hat das doch eh schon gemacht, und wenn er das nicht gemacht hat,
ist die Frage warum es gerade 2 Minuten gedauert hat, Web Interface läuft halt auf PHP, das
kannste nicht auf PHP schieben, so also wir haben jetzt einen Encrypted Disk, das heißt
wir brauchen jetzt ein Filesystem, oder aber es ist wirklich so, dass das dann erst auf
die Platte schreibt, man rebooten funktioniert, aber die Platte ist nach wie vor verschlüsselt,
ok, Create, select device, äh nein, äh ich müsste jetzt eigentlich ein Encrypted Device
bekommen, ach hier Unlock, 1 2 3 4 5 6 Unlock, ok jetzt aber, jetzt kann ich Filesystem erstellen,
da ist es, der Lux Encrypted Container, alles klar, so, aja ja, ne ne, wir machen gar nichts,
wir lassen es einfach so, do you really want to format, yes, x4, please, jetzt kommt das
gleiche wieder, gut, man merkt schon, es ist langsamer als vorher, viel langsamer als vorher,
wenn ich jetzt apply drücke, geht es wahrscheinlich kaputt, oh die Playlist ist vorbei, da war
die Playlist wieder neu an, gut, die Samba geht grad nicht, es läuft da nicht, oh kann
nicht funktionieren, so jetzt müssen wir kurz warten, bis das x4 Filesystem angelegt hat
für uns, ach ja, übrigens vorhin noch ganz vergessen, wo ich mich darüber ausgelassen
hab, wie der Raspberry Pi am CPU Limit ist, sollte die also gar noch auf die Idee kommen
da zusätzlich dazu, vielleicht zwei Platten anzuschließen und da einen Software Raid drüber
zu machen, vergiss es, dann hast du vielleicht noch 30MB die Sekunde übers Netzwerk am Ende
und das Ding brummt auf allen vier Kern zu 100%, hast du einen Kühler dran, nö, ich
musste ja meinen Kühler runterbauen, weil das Gehäuse den HDMI Ausgang blockiert hat,
ich hab aber nen Passivkühler drauf, wir gucken mal wie laut sind V, C, ne V, GEN,
was war das Temp, ne, V, C, GEN, Measure Temp, so kryptische Dinger immer, 57 Grad, easy,
kein Problem, 57 Grad, juckt doch keinen, äh, Kelmo, ja, Single Threaded ist es auf
jeden Fall so, machen wir noch nen TMAX auf, nicht installiert, Gotteslästerung, ja, geht
nicht neu dank Sensors, gute Frage, schon nicht ausprobiert, ne, und ich will eigentlich
das Paket auch nicht installieren, weil ich hab ja hier schon was, ja, gucken wir uns
das mal an, unten machen wir nen Hardtop auf und gucken wie rausgelastet er ist, aktuell
ist er nicht so ausgelastet, aber gleich wird's hot, so, also, ja, ich applye ja mal, ist
ja gut, Open Media Wall ist ja gut, ich applye, weil du's bist, ich frag mich halt was der
da jetzt 3 Stunden macht, schreib dir irgendwas auf die SD-Karte oder so, hm, gut, Samba,
wo sind wir, da, Windows Share, enable, save, naja, nervt nicht, add, so, wo ist unser Folder,
ah ne, muss man erst hinzufügen, device, ne, ok, warum ist das jetzt nicht da, weil ich
nicht applied hab wahrscheinlich, weil ich nicht applied hab, ok, ich applye, ist gut,
ich geb mich geschlagen, ich applye, ich weiß, dass ein Lüfter was bringt, ich hatte das
doch auch im Gehäuse mit Lüfter, aber, das Gehäuse war halt zu fett, da ging kein HDMI
dran, und der Chat wollt ja unbedingt, dass ich HDMI anschließe, der Chat ist mal wieder
schuld, wie immer, Chat, immer das gleiche mit euch, schlimm, ok, der applied aber ganz
schön lang jetzt, apply, apply, so, jetzt haben wir es, ok, share, add, was, select
the Chat-Folder, will ich ja nicht, add, device, warum nicht, ah, ah, ich hab was vergessen
glaube ich, warte, warte, ich muss das ja mounten vorher, oder wie war das, ich muss
das ja mounten, das hab ich ja schon wieder vergessen, hab ich ja schon wieder vergessen,
da, mount, muss man ja vorher machen, ich hab nicht genug applied, genau, das war ein,
ein nicer Witz, so, ich apply jetzt nicht, jetzt share, add, neuen Folder, jetzt device,
da ist es, so, blub, mir doch egal, wer das heißt, permissions, everyone, save, guests,
yes, save, gut, jetzt apply ich, jetzt, gut, jetzt wird applied, und jetzt gucken wir auch,
ob es läuft, grep, netstat, tulben, grep, gucken wir, ob samba läuft, da ist es, samba
ist am start, jetzt schauen wir mal, wie warm das ganze wird, warte, ich brauch credentials,
warum brauch ich credentials, ich hab doch eingestellt, es soll, es soll browsable für
alle sein, oder nicht, ah, der ist noch beim applying, sorry, er applied ja noch, er applied
ja noch, das hab ich jetzt nicht, dachte, der ist schneller, mit dem applying, mich
würde mal interessieren, was der da eigentlich genau applied für 5 Minuten, ist er kaputt,
was fällst du von WSL 2, wir haben uns jetzt mal im stream angeguckt vor 2, 3 Wochen, ich
fand es eigentlich ganz brauchbar, CPU-Auslastung ist nicht hoch, da macht nix, oh er ist fertig,
darf ich jetzt, darf ich jetzt, ah, jetzt darf ich, ok, blub, moment, downloads, dann
haben wir die Windows 10 ISO wollten wir haben, so, und jetzt ist er bestimmt viel langsamer,
ah, ja, ja, ja, da geht es nicht allzu viel, guck, Raspberry nass, ja, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ja, das Ding ist komplett am Limit, das schwankt immer so, weil er wahrscheinlich
irgendwelche Buffer vollschreibt, und dann irgendwann mal Flashed auf Disc und deswegen
hat er die Spikes drinne, aber der ist komplett, der ist komplett dicht, also, siehs ja auch
hier am Schwanken, Samba IO Encryption, bringt das Ding, bringt das Ding an die Grenze, wenn
Wenn man damit leben kann, also wenn einem das reicht, dass man da so im Durchschnitt
mit keine Ahnung, 50 MB die Sekunde rumwurstet, dann ist es okay, aber für ein bisschen mehr
Geld kann man deutlich besseres nachbauen.
So warm wird er gar nicht.
Probier doch mal FTP, nee, mal gucken wie schneller es von Kopieren auf dem Samba ohne
über mich zu kopieren, wobei ich bin gar nicht so sicher bin ob er da gar nicht über
mich kopiert, nee ich glaub der kopiert nicht über mich, ich glaub Samba ist clever genug
und checkt das, macht das auf Serverseite.
Ja das ist jetzt natürlich komplett am Limit und das liegt daran, weil er wahrscheinlich
entschlüsseln muss, lesen, verschlüsseln, schreiben.
Was kannst du für Alternativen empfehlen, also wenn du was ähnlich im ähnlichen Preissegment
suchst und was aber auch schon fix und fertig quasi kommt, wo du einfach nur deine Festplatte
einschlöpseln musst, dann empfehle ich dir sowas hier.
Der ist wirklich gut dafür, gibt es auch eine kleine Variante für 2,5 Zoll Platten, so
einen hab ich auch drüben bei mir im Wohnzimmer stehen für Fernsehaufnahmen, haben wir sogar
mal im Stream zusammengebaut, können euch daran erinnern wo wir ein TV Headend selbst
kompiliert haben, dass der Kram funktioniert, brauch ich mittlerweile nicht mehr, nee nicht
mehr, das kann ich empfehlen, das ist ganz gut, ist ungefähr ähnlich teuer wie ein Raspberry
Pi, vielleicht sogar ein bisschen günstiger als ein Raspberry Pi und danach sind die Intel
Low Power Plattformen ziemlich gut.
Basti, wie hab ich das schon gemacht, guck mal, ich hab ihn sogar noch offen, der ist
tatsächlich gut, allerdings ist der Formfaktor von dem Gehäuse ziemlich doof.
115 Euro ohne Ramier, mal warten bis es das in Deutschland zu kaufen gibt, also ich hab
hier aktuell was sehr ähnliches, ich hab hier aktuell ein, ich hab hier aktuell als
Nass sowas hier, nicht exakt das, sondern das da hab ich aktuell als Nass, das Board,
da kann man sich echt nett beschweren, hast zwei SATA Anschlüsse, hast einen Anschluss
für eine PCIe Karte, zweifach glaube, zweifach eingebunden, vierfach, nee ich glaub sogar
vierfach, vierfach, und es ist halt ein ordentlicher Formfaktor, zweifach, zweifach, das Nass
haben wir mal im Stream zusammengestellt und bisschen rumgebaut, rein von der Hardware
ist das hier ziemlich gut, sowohl vom Preis her als auch von den Specks, was mich halt
da nervt ist an dem Ding, dass es halt so ein kack Formfaktor hat und in kein ordentliches
Gehäuse reinpasst, also es passt schon rein, aber dann wackelt es oder es guckt hinten
raus oder es sind Lücken, aber man kann das natürlich schon in ein normales Gehäuse rein
basteln, warum nicht, hindert einen ja keiner dran, doofe Frage, was genau macht denn das
Nass, äh gerade macht das gar nichts, weil wir gerade was kopiert haben und es ist fertig
kopieren, löschen wir mal, also schnell ist es nicht, oder meinst du wofür das Nass allgemein
da ist, dann hab ich dich vielleicht falsch verstanden, ähm Finky, RG, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön, excellent Subscription, huge Sub, mal gucken, dass ich keine Subs vergessen
hab, ich hab eben heute noch gar nicht in die Liste geguckt, gab zwar schon einige, aber
ich hab bestimmt, so wie ich mich kenn, ein paar übersehen, ne hab ich nicht, der Martin
war zuletzt davor, der ist schon ein Jahr dabei, da ist das, da platzt das, also nach zwei
Jahren Wubbler-Stream, dann ist wirklich, dann müsst ihr aufpassen, weil dann ist akute
Gehirnexplosionsgefahr, du hast verdient Max, das ist schön, wenn du das so siehst, excellent.
So, also man sieht jetzt auch wieder hier, dass der Raspberry Pi halt nicht so geil ist,
wenn man ein bisschen Performance von seinem Nass braucht, ne, ich find das ist relativ
offensichtlich, wenn man sich die, oh fuck, ok, das war jetzt keine gute Idee, dass Windos
den Kram parallel kopiert, ja, aber man sieht, die Performance ist halt tatsächlich nicht
gut.
Taugt der Raspberry Pi als Minecraft-Server, ja, das denk ich schon, ich bin zwar kein
Minecraft-Pro, aber als Minecraft-Server dürfte der Raspberry Pi ganz gut sein und da lohnt
sich vielleicht auch der mit 8GB je nach Größe der Welt, guck mal, wie lahm das ist und
wieder schwankt, das ist doch für'n Arsch, das ist doch Mist hier, guckt euch das mal
an, das ist wirklich grottische Performance, wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, also man würde
sogar noch einen Software-Rate machen, dann ist ganz für'n Arsch, dann krebt sie permanent
bei 30MB die Sekunde rum, man kann auch, ja ja, Replace, alles gut, der Toaster hat Recht,
wenn man Desktop-Hardware verwenden möchte, wenn einem das jetzt nicht wegen Stromverbrauch
oder so nervt, kann man sich auch einen super Nass aus aktuellen AMD-CPUs zusammenbauen,
keine Frage, das geht, allerdings, ich finde als Nass-Plattform die Low-Power-CPUs von
Intel sehr praktisch, sowas hier zum Beispiel, das kostet weniger, ist Performance-mäßig
vollkommen ausreichend, vor allem auch dank Hardware-Ecryption und es braucht halt so gut
wie nichts, wie gesagt, ich drehe mich mal kurz um, mein Nass braucht gerade Eidl, meine
Platten sind unten, Moment, ich sehe es nicht, ich muss mal kurz hinterfahren mit dem Stuhl,
12,5 Watt Eidl, das wahrscheinlich macht sogar ein bisschen was, weil normalerweise
ist es um die 10, wie gesagt, wenn die Platten standby sind, weil wenn die Platten grödeln,
dann ist klar, dass es ein bisschen mehr braucht, ist ja immer so, ein altes Notebook könnte
doch sicher auch als Nass taugen, ja, es taugt potentiell alles als Nass, was dir von der
Performance reicht und wo du die Platten dran kriegst, aber beim Notebook hast du halt wieder
die Sache, du musst die Platten oben drauf legen, du brauchst ein paar USB-Adapter, du
musst die Kramer irgendwie angeschlossen bekommen, im Notebook ist da meistens auch
nicht so viel USB-Schnittstellen, also klar, wenn du vielleicht ein älteres Notebook hast,
das schon USB-3 hat, und ein ordentliches USB-3, und du holst den Adapter USB-3 und willst
nur eine Platte zur Verfügung stellen, klar, kannst du machen, Vorteil am Notebook ist
tatsächlich, das geht nicht einfach aus, dafür ist es echt praktisch, Dom PC, 6 Monate,
Massive Brain Subscription, Dankeschön, man kann sich auch einen Server kaufen, man kann
ganz viel machen, ja, kann man auch machen, also was ganz gut ist, wenn man nicht mit
Inter-Low-Power-Plattform machen will, sind die, äh, waren das Dell Mikro, nee, HP Mikro
waren das, ne, die etwas älteren, die kriegt man auch günstig, oder auch nicht mehr, wenn
man die nicht mehr kriegt, dann hat sich das jetzt erledigt, ähm, die sind ganz gut,
die kann man sich geben, allerdings weiß ich nicht, wie gut die neuen sind, ähm, aber
ich weiß dann, dass viele Leute sich versuchen, damit einen Raspberry Pi was zu stricken,
und was man halt auch hier jetzt gerade wieder sieht, ist, dass der Raspberry Pi halt für,
wenn man auch nur halbwegs darauf, auf Performance bedacht ist, also, muss man sagen, wenn ein
Performance nicht total egal ist, dann sollte man keinen Raspberry nehmen, also, oder, man
sollte einen Raspberry nur nehmen, wenn ein Performance wirklich total egal ist beim Lass,
aber wenn ein Performance beim Lass total egal ist, dann könnten die meisten Leute ihre
externe Platte auch an die Fritzbox stöpseln, die ist zwar noch immer langsamer als der
Raspberry Pi, also noch mal eine ganze Ecke langsamer, aber die hat wahrscheinlich fast
jeder, also der USB Anschluss an der Fritzbox ist wirklich die Ausgeburt des Bösen, den
will glaube ich keiner verwenden. Kann die Fritzbox mittlerweile was neueres
als SMP1? Das ist eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung, ich habe die Fritzbox noch nie als
NAS verwendet, noch nie. Theoretisch können ja sogar Mikrotik-Router Samba bereitstellen
über USB, macht wahrscheinlich auch keiner. Also, das sind alles so Notlösungen, wenn
man was ordentliches haben will und sich keine Arbeit machen möchte, dann kauft man was
fertiges, dann kauft man irgendwie Synology oder QNAP oder sonst was und ansonsten, wenn
man auch was ziemlich easy haben will, aber wo man sich ein bisschen selbst darum kümmern
will, dann würde ich mir den Odroid HC2 kaufen, da ist ja auch schon alles fix und fertig,
man muss plus die Platte dranstecken, man muss aber halt das Linux selbst installieren, dafür
muss man sonst nichts großartig machen, also hardware-mäßig schon fix und fertig, halt
nur einen Slot für eine Platte und einen USB für eine Backup-Platte, aber das reicht
den meisten Leuten ja, im Low-Budget-Segment sucht ja jetzt keiner nach Kisten mit 5 Platten-Einschümen
oder so und den meisten reicht das ja auch, eine Möglichkeit für eine Backup-Platte ist
aber Pflicht, kann ich euch sagen, also ich würde kein NAS betreiben, wo auch nur irgendwie
wichtige Daten drauf kommen, ohne dass das Ding zumindest die Möglichkeit hat eine Backup-Platte
anzuschließen, dazu reicht ja auch schon ein Grotten-Lama-Ola-USB-2.0-Anschluss meinetwegen,
aber Möglichkeit für eine Backup-Platte muss es geben und sei es nur, dass man einmal nachts
in Ersung macht, von erster auf die zweite Platte, das reicht alles, aber komplett ohne
Backup-Platte ist scheiße, es sei denn, und das ist jetzt eigentlich was mir einfällt,
man verwendet das nur als temporäre Ablage für Sachen, die eh nach 5 Minuten nicht mehr
relevant sind, aber wer macht das daheim schon und wer braucht da so eine geringe Performance
für?
Also ein Odroid-HC2 ist gut, wenn man ein Betriebssystem selbst installieren kann, allerdings
es günstig haben will und die Hardware nichts bauen will, ansonsten nimmt man sich eine
Low-Power-Intel-Plattform und baut sich selbst was zusammen, das ist auch gut, oder wenn
man gar keinen Bock hat, kauft man sich ein Cyanology oder QNAP, da muss man sagen, die
Dinger sind gar nicht so teuer, also wenn man jetzt kein 10 Gigabit nass haben will,
oder irgendwie Wettbewerb gewinnen möchte, wer baut das günstige, preisleistungsmäßig
sind die Cyanology-Dinger gar nicht so verkehrt.
Deine Mahnung zu SnapRaid, ehm, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, ich hab nur gelesen
was es ist, diese Geschichte mit, dass du quasi mehrere Platten auf Feilebene zusammenfasst,
richtig, ehm, dass du auch unterschiedliche große Platten und so zusammenfassen kannst,
eigentlich eine gute Idee, habe ich aber noch nie verwendet, ich hatte die ganze Zeit in
meiner, in meinem fetten 4HE-Server, den man ja auch hier mal im Video gesehen hat,
ich zeig das ja ab und zu mal, weil, immer fragen, den hatte ich ja die ganze Zeit laufen,
da oben die fette Kiste hier, die hatte ich jetzt ja die ganze Zeit laufen, ehm, da waren,
ehm, Rate 5 mit 10TB Platten drinnen, aber das habe ich ja mittlerweile abgelöst, weil
es einfach kompletter Overkill war und ich mit der Kiste nichts von dem gemacht habe,
was ich eigentlich vor hatte zu machen und vieles schon wieder runtergebaut habe davon,
was jetzt gar nicht mehr darauf läuft, habe ich jetzt auch eine Intel Low Power Plattform
mit einfach einer 12TB Platte dran und einer Backup Platte und fertig ist.
Kommt's Update-Video zum Surfer-Raum, ja, kommt, ich weiß aber nicht wann, so und ansonsten
ist der Raspberry Pi halt, so wie ich es mir gedacht habe, nicht geeignet, wenn ein Performance
nicht total egal ist.
Kommt mal das Video zum Rechensendrum, ja, auch schon aufgenommen, Unterschied WD Gold
versus WD Red, wahrscheinlich kein großer, ich weiß nicht, was, was die dazu sagen, aber
wahrscheinlich kein großer, bisher war es ja so, WD Red ist ja quasi so die, die Nass,
Home, Home Nass, Nass Geschichte von WD und Gold, also wenn es die gleichen Spezifikationen
hat, also sprich gleiche Umdrehungen, gleiche Größe, gleiche Speichertechnologie, dann
würde ich sagen, ist der Unterschied zu vernachlässigen.
E3 Status Rust habe ich, aber ich weiß den Unterschied zwischen WD Gold und WD Red jetzt
nicht fundiert irgendwie, ich würde aber mal so, ich vermute aber einfach mal, dass
es keinen großen Unterschied macht.
Wo es einen relativ großen Unterschied gab, war zwischen WD Red und WD, was haben die
sagen, WD Black gibt es glaube ich auch noch, WD Green hatten sie früher, die Green und
WD Red war früher tatsächlich ein großer Unterschied, weil die Green Platten nicht
so oft, also die mochten das glaube ich nicht so oft, wenn die öfters anlaufen müssen und
sowas.
Oder war es umgedreht, das, so bitte ich hatte schon ein paar WD Green Platten die
mir verreckt sind, ich glaube Gold ist mit Helium gefüllt, ah exzellent, so mag es sein,
ja so genau weiß ich nicht, es gibt ja eh nur noch zwei Festplattenhersteller, gibt
ja kaum noch was, die wirklich selbst bauen, wann kommen eigentlich RGB HDDs, gibt es bestimmt
schon, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn es es nicht schon gibt, ja hier guck das doch,
RGB, ah da haste doch, da haste doch schon alles schön mit RGB, was ist das denn, RGB,
RGB SSD gibt es bestimmt auch schon Leute, gibt es garantiert, also gerade bei SSDs hätte
es mich auch gewundert, wenn es das nicht als RGB gibt, es gibt ja mittlerweile alles
mit RGB, RGB ist eigentlich der schwachsinnigste Trend was Performance angeht, irgendwie der
letzten Jahre, weil es bringt halt gar nichts und ich finde, ist aber meine persönliche
Meinung, dass RGB dem, auch jetzt der Optik nicht unbedingt sowas bringt großartig, nichts
desto trotz, habe ich selbst RGB am Start und guck mal auch ganz gerne in den Rechner rein,
aktuell habe ich allerdings alles aus, auf der einen Seite finde ich RGB doof, aber tja,
was willst du machen, ich habe es selbst mittlerweile ja und dann gucke ich halt mal ab und zu in
den Rechner und sehe, ah guck mal er leuchtet das Nvidia Logo, es leuchtet ein bisschen
rot, es leuchtet ein bisschen gelb, Tastatur leuchtet grün, äh nicht grün, blau, Maus
leuchtet gar nicht, die habe ich ausgeschaltet, wie würdest du von außen auf der Nass zugreifen,
gar nicht nach Möglichkeit, also nur wenn es einen ganz driftigen Grund gibt, achso ja
ich sollte mal weiter, VPN auf Fritzbox und somit ins Heimnetz oder VPN direkt aufs Nass,
äh also, VPN direkt aufs Nass geht ja so ohne weiteres gar nicht, da muss ja, du kommst
ja von außen nicht dran, da müsstest du noch irgendwelche, ok müsstest du Ports weiterleiten,
das beste wäre, also wenn du wirklich von außen auf das Nass mit deinen internen Daten
zugreifen willst und es nicht irgendwie anders machen kannst mit, dass du die Daten irgendwie
züngst auf den Server, was auch immer angenommen, wir gehen jetzt mal von außen, du musst wirklich
drauf zugreifen, dann würde ich, dann würde ich gucken, dass ich das, dass ich VPN mache
auf den Router, allerdings würde ich gucken, dass ich ein eigenes VPN Netzwerk habe, also
sprich alle VPN Clients kommen in ein eigenes Netz und das einzige was freigeschaltet wird
ist der Zugriff auf diese, auf dieses Nass, so würde ich das machen, wenn ichs machen
müsste, also sprich du wählst dich per VPN in dein Router ein, dein VPN Client kriegt
eine IP aus einem eigenen VPN Netz und das einzige wo Rechner aus diesem VPN Netz hin
dürfen ist zu deinem Nass, so würde ich das wahrscheinlich machen, wenn ichs machen müsste
und dann halt das Nass so weit wie möglich absichern, dass man vielleicht, vielleicht
kannst du es auch im zweiten Port laufen lassen, dass du nur dahin freischaltest, so getrennt
wie irgendwie möglich, ich bin aber kein großer Fan von quasi Nass mit privaten Daten,
vielleicht auch als wichtigen Daten, Daten die ziemlich privat sind, was auch immer da
drauf was, ich bin aber kein großer Fan von das überhaupt vom Internet aus in irgendeiner
Art und Weise zugänglich zu machen, klar manchmal ist es erforderlich, wobei man sich
da auch überlegen muss tut es nicht, ein kleiner, kleiner Teil der Daten die man braucht, braucht
man wirklich Zugriff auf alle Daten und wenn es ein kleiner Teil tut, dann würde ich mir
überlegen, ok ist es nicht sinnvoller die Sachen zu sünken, ja hast du schon was von
Asusgate gehört, nein was ist Asusgate, Asus jawohl gemerkt, Asusgate, ist das was neues
oder ist das was altes oder, welchen Hersteller würdest du raten Dell oder HPs verkommen egal,
alles was preisleistungsmäßig am besten passt, oh es hat mich schon wieder ausgelockt, lull,
wir gucken mal noch schnell was es noch für Plugins gibt, Logins, ShareRoute, ok brauchen
man vielleicht wenn man auf einer SSD installiert hat und die SSD sharen will, was wo Asus Router
komplett die Nass freigegeben haben, nein das kenne ich nicht, ein weiterer Grund warum
ich so Dinger nicht verwende, ich verwende was ordentliches als Router zwischen mir und
dem Provider bzw. zwischen Provider, Router und internem Rest, Backup, Borgbackup, Borgbackup
ist übrigens das beste meiner Ansicht nach, das beste Backup Programm was es gibt, Automatically
Synchronized Shared Folder to USB, ok das könnte auch praktisch sein, Downloader, ist
bestimmt auch nützlich für manche Leute, ein Borgbackup ist, VM ist für VMs und so
ist das Top aber beste Sache für wenn man Linux und Windows upgraden will und ein bisschen
Cromando Zeilen benutzen kann ist Borgbackup es gibt nichts Vergleichbares, FlashMemory,
Lux Encryption das haben wir drauf, LVM brauchen wir nicht, was Nil, Nilfs, was ist denn Nilfs
aktuell System, oh das ist ja torwar aktuell, Downloader, irgendwas, was auch immer, SimLynx,
ZFS, ah es gibt ein ZFS Plugin, ok, gut es wird wahrscheinlich nicht an das Management
von FreeNAS was ZFS angeht rankommen, das ist ja so der Verkaufsschlager, der Selling
Point von FreeNAS oder jetzt neuerdings ja TrueNAS die haben es ja umbenannt oder haben
es jetzt irgendwie zusammengefügt oder so, TrueNAS, True, LV, ich wusste das irgendwie
einer damit anfängt ey, was macht ZFS eigentlich so toll, oh einige, einige Sachen, zum Beispiel
ich sag dir grad mal was, ich wollte mir das Borgbackup GUI angucken, ah das ist Mac OS
Only, Mac OS und Linux Desktop, ok, also was macht ZFS so gut, da muss ich jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen weiter ausholen, komm ich bin grad low brain, ich suche einfach mal Lisse
Vorteile von ZFS und gebe da mal einen Senf zu, also eine Sache die ich persönlich als
riesen Vorteil von ZFS empfinde ist, dass alles schon drinnen ist was man braucht, Encryption
mittlerweile drinnen, RAID Geschichten mittlerweile drinnen, Validierungsgeschichten mittlerweile
drinnen, Volume Management mittlerweile drinnen, Samba Verwaltung mittlerweile, also ZFS ist
quasi alles in einem, was man irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise braucht was File System angeht,
so den Rest arbeite ich mich mal in irgendeiner Liste ab, oh what the, jaja ist gut, ist aber
eine doofe Liste, steht nicht so viel drinnen, GIGA, Moment GIGA erklärt mir ZFS, ich bin
mal gespannt, explain vor Beginn, das ist gut, blablabla, gut hab ich schon gesagt, ist quasi
ein LVM mit dabei, achja Snapshots ganz vergessen, du hast eingebaute Snapshot Funktion die ist
ziemlich gut in ZFS, du kannst quasi Snapshots komplett übers Netzwerk schicken von einem
Rechner zum anderen und Snapshots verbrauchen standardmäßig keinen Speicherplatz, Snapshots
ist in ZFS ein bisschen was anderes, also da wird nicht irgendwie die Platte komplett
kopiert sondern das ist im Prinzip wenn du so willst ein Zeiger auf einen aktuellen Stand
und erst wenn der Stand abweicht dann werden die Snapshots größer mit der Zeit, also Snapshots
ist eine gute Geschichte, wie gesagt Raids Kram ist eingebaut, ein Nachteil von ZFS ist
dass es relativ komplex ist von der Verwaltung her, aber so ein paar Kleinigkeiten, also
wenn man sich mal dran gewöhnt hat gehts eigentlich und ein weiterer Nachteil von ZFS, sofern man
als Nachteil sehen will ist, dass es halt relativ viel RAM sich gönnt, ZFS funktioniert auch
mit weniger RAM, ZFS funktioniert übrigens auch ohne ECC RAM oder sowas, gibt ja Leute
die sagen unter 48, zumindest sagen das die ganzen FreeNAS Fanatiker, glaub was die sagen
ist unter 48 GB RAM ECC Speicher muss man erst gar nicht anfangen, das ist natürlich
kompletter Schwachsinn, wenn ich einen NAS betreiben will für 1-2 User daheim ohne großartig
parallele Zugriffe, ohne irgendwelche Sachen die ich garantieren muss, ohne irgendwelche
wahnsinnig Performance Anforderungen ist das komplett überdimensionierter Blödsinn, braucht
kein Mensch, da reicht ganz normale dimensionierte Server aus, das wirst du wahrscheinlich auch
mit 2, 3, 4 GB betreiben können, wenn du da keine großartigen Anforderungen dran hast
ja und das mit ECC Speicher stimmt auch nicht, also es hat einen wahren Kern, aber wenn man
ZFS dann vergleicht mit normalen anderen Dateisystemen, wird ZFS ja nicht schlechter ohne ECC, du
erkennst halt manche Fehler nicht, was aber andere Dateisysteme auch nicht machen würden.
Natürlich ist ECC Speicher sinnvoll, keine Frage, aber wenn man bereit ist das ohne ECC
zu betreiben, ist ZFS nicht weniger sinnvoll dafür, da sind ein bisschen viele Mythen auch
die sich da am ZFS ranken, dann auch so Sachen wie 1 GB RAM pro, was ist das, wie war das,
1 GB RAM pro 10 GB Speicher oder sowas, irgendwas in der Richtung, also komplett, also ich meine
Erfahrungen nachher komplett aus Schwachsinn, wenn man das im Heimbereich verwenden will,
ach genau 1 GB RAM für 1 TB Speicherplatz, ist aber für den Heimbereich vollkommen utopisch
und braucht man nicht.
Ein größter Nachteil von ZFS in der Heimanwendung ist einfach, dass es ein bisschen kompliziert
zu administrieren ist.
Janek, wie lange wir noch machen, keine Ahnung, viertel Stunde oder so, der kickt mich gerne
raus hier, ich habe übrigens meine USB immer noch nicht die Batterie getauscht, also beim
nächsten Stromausfall ist es RIP, bin zu faul gewesen, kann man mal Updates machen, zack,
mal gucken wie schnell das geht, gibt es was vergleichbares zu APC, klar, ich hatte früher
so eine billige APC, so eine fette APC Steckdosenleiste, mittlerweile habe ich eine Cyber Power, vielleicht
die hier, ich weiß es gar nicht, ja so eine ähnliche habe ich, der ausschlaggebende
war, dass die gebaut ist für 19 Zoll Racks, dass sie auch einen HE braucht, dass du sie
per USB an den Server anschließen kannst, der sich automatisch runterfährt, also sprich,
dass man sich Informationen von der USB holen kann.
Das ist auch wichtig, USBs ohne Möglichkeit die vom Server abzufragen ist immer doof,
weil, wenn das ein bisschen länger dauert, der Vorteil von der USB ist ja gerade, dass
system bezahlt haben sich runter zu fahren wenn es eng wird das reicht wenn
es usb verbindung ist so und ansonsten ist eigentlich wurscht ob cyberpower
apc oder sonst was ihr genau eton oder wie man die ausspricht gibt es auch noch
von denen habe ich keine habe ich keine erfahrung mit und aber meiner cyberpower
usf also quasi bei dem ding ist halt die batterie jetzt verreckt nach ein paar
jahren aber komplett verreckt so dass auch der server ausgegangen ist der dran
war also eigentlich mega fail wenn du das überlegst dass ist dass das server
abkackt wenn die usf abkackt also zumindest wenn der strom da ist und die
usf abkackt solltest du weiter funktionieren ja also ich hatte quasi
den ausfall nicht durch stromausfall sondern durch den usf ausfall usf
applied ja laufend wie macht man ja nicht updates install exzellent
hast du dein netzwerk extra noch gegenüber spannung blitzschlag oder der
gleichen abgesicherte habe ich nicht
also nicht mehr als was das haus e-shop hat
habe da nicht extra noch mal irgendwas dazwischen
so ansonsten gibt es hier glaube ich jetzt in media volt selbst nicht
sonderlich viel spannendes noch zu gucken performance statistik muss ich
applyen und sich applyen ich muss applyen was denn sonst exzellent was sagst du zum
16 jährigen der die die welche waren das noch mal bin wir gar nicht sicher ob ich
das mitgekriegt habe wahrscheinlich habe ich mitgekriegt aber ich kann mich jetzt
nicht dran erinnern ich vergesse den ganzen kram ziemlich
schnell mittlerweile da ist es ja laufend irgendwas ich könnte die auch nicht mehr
die stieb die die größten sicherheitslücken der letzten 14 tage sagen
kriegt es vielleicht noch zwei drei tage hin und danach merke ich mir nicht mehr
wenn es nicht relevant ist für uns auf der arbeit außer es ist was ganz großes
melddown geschichte shell schock was hatten wir sonst noch alles
die microsoft die microsoft viren scanner lücke manche sachen merkt man
sich schon hart plied hart plied genau also bedingungen paar sachen merkt man
sich schon aber nee also zum kosten ist das merke ich mir dass wenn das nicht
relevant für uns auf der arbeit ist eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht mehr wir
haben noch kein ctf hier gemacht wir haben auch noch kein competitive
programming wettbewerb oder sowas mitgemacht das ist da bin ich zu
low-brain für das wird zu anstrengend und ich bin zu schlecht und zu langsam
was gibt es dann so für gute cases für ein selbstgebautes nass leider nicht so
viele also es gibt ein paar ganz billige die sind ok aber aus dem ich weiß aus
dem kopf gerade keine guten also es gibt also willst du welche 19 zoll
rekbauweise oder willst du darf es auch in den tausen sein aber wenn sie
nämlich auch ein tower sein darf und du nicht unbedingt vorne einschübe haben
möchtest dass du hotswap rahmen hast dann kannst du fast jeden beliebigen
tower nehmen 19 zoll baue weise und einschübe für wechselrahmen dann wird
es dann schon ein bisschen komplizierter und auch ziemlich teuer teilweise
ja was sie du hast vollkommen recht die letzten jahre man trifft also jahre
wirklich schon ja gerade dass irgendwo eingebrochen wurde daten geleakt wurden
und sonst was das hast du ja fast täglich das juckt mittlerweile echt
kein mehr und die leute sind schon so überfordert mit den informationen dass
sie sich dass die haben die also die kunden haben es komplett aufgegeben
mittlerweile die sagen sich ich habe doch eh keine wahl ich will ich will diesen
ganzen komfort und die apps verwenden und das zeug und wenn einer data
preach legt mich ich will es gar nicht mehr wissen so denken die meisten leute
mittlerweile das juckt die überhaupt nicht mehr
warum habe ich jetzt eigentlich monitoring eingeschaltet wenn dann
überhaupt nichts passiert aus smart guck mal das ist für big brain leute
festblatt monitoring for five herz gut dass ich monitor eingeschaltet habe und
nix sehe
exzellent
die meisten leute denken sich bei daten liegs nur noch das hier es geht in das
eine rein und das andere aus
ja bei abos fünf lücken gefunden abos nicht der schlosshersteller also wenn die
it von abos so sicher ist wie manche schlösser dann wundert mich das nicht
darf man links posten wenn es nach von meiner seite aus darfst du links posten
ich weiß nicht ob du links posten darfst also ob es erlaubt ist dass sie den
halt jetzt irgendwie postet aber ansonsten wegen mir kann so schon machen
ab jetzt nicht verfügbar man muss mal kurz gucken wo ich darf ja hier mal
wieder nicht copy pasten
irgendwie passt das und formel eins nicht zusammen aber was auch immer
ab der nicht verfügbar was das hat schwachstellen in ip basierten
überwachungskameras dazu habe dazu habe ich auch was ja das ist das einzige wo
ich wirklich mal den hersteller kontaktiert habe wo ich mir wo ich mir
die mühe gemacht habe echt mal den hersteller zu kontaktieren als ich bei
einer kamera gesehen habe dass man mit einem köln direkt das root password
auslesen kann das war wirklich sowas von fail und der hat erst gar nicht
gecheckt was ich von ihm will der hat der hat erst mal mich auf die fq auf der
webseite verwiesen habe gesagt ja lesen sich mal die fq durch habe ich dann auf
github habe ich auf github hochgeladen wie es geht weil das halt auf github war
also sprich einer zugänglichen seite hat er dann auf einmal angefangen ob ich
nicht github link wieder löschen könnte also der war nicht so sehr darauf bedacht
jetzt die firma möglichst schnell zu updaten sondern dass die github link
auch ja wieder lösche ja das war es aber hat die firmen nachher gefixt zwei
monate später oder so also da hat schwachstellen in ip basierten
überwachungskameras gefunden im hersteller gemeldet zwar hätten sich
die software schwachstellen mit einem update beseitigen lassen
der hersteller ist aber nicht mehr in der lage ein update bereitzustellen
der hat keinen bock quasi aus war auf deutsch zu sagen also können hätte
wahrscheinlich schon können na oder aber ne der hat das bord
wahrscheinlich inklusive stk und allem aus china gekauft und die chinesen hatten
keinen bock mehr ein update zu produzieren ja bin kurs genau so dachte
ich mir gerade die haben die kriegst du immer gebacken
so war es routine ende 2018 5 schwachstellen überwachungskameras einem
deutschen ach guck mal da ist er der dwingkorb
nice fix
fix aber das war da war da zufällig auch dieser hersteller mit dabei
weil bei dem habe ich das gefunden das weiß ich eben was ich vorhin erzählt
habe mit root password über karl aus auslesen oder war das andere
ach abus stimmt ja hast ja gesagt abus
aufgefallen
unter umgehung der üblichen fasen von ok immerhin immerhin also das ist ja
schon mal was ja dass das dass die wenigstens mitmachen
das ist ja schon mal was
ja ab jetzt nicht möglich ja das ist halt fehlen ja das dachte ich mir die
haben sich das bord und den kram und das entwickler kitten alles vom aus china
oder in dem fall von aus thailand eingekauft kriegst jetzt selbst können
sie selbst nicht mehr benutzen
tja verschissen würde ich sagen
ja pech gehabt das problem ist nur wahrscheinlich kriegen das 90 prozent
der kunden gar nicht mit die frage ist halt ob abus jetzt selbst zu den kunden
geht uns und sagt hier wir können das austauschen falls sie das überhaupt wissen wer
da was hat die meisten leute werden es gar nicht mitkriegen
wahrscheinlich kriegen es die meisten gar nicht mit
was haben wir eigentlich hier diese news artikel noch auf moment
jetzt soll moment warte mal kurz warte mal kurz es gibt gibt es doch schon
ne zum glück zum glück das letzte was ich brauchte ist noch mit
browser was ich halt immer lustig finde ist dass wenn man immer dass es nicht so
oft mitgekriegt hat man neigt dazu zu denken dass quasi große hersteller das
schon alles immer richtig machen werden also diese denkweise merke ich bei
leuten bei uns auf der arbeit die damit nicht so in kontakt geraten mit super
tollen enterprise business anwendungen die dann auch nur haufe haufen krebs sind
meistens zumindest oder auch privat also dass es so viele leute die der meinung
ist doch großer renommierte hersteller die wissen noch wie das funktioniert oder
das wird schon das wird schon alles funktioniert gar kein problem die
wissen was sie machen das ist halt nicht so gerade enterprise
business software ist der größte kacke von allen umso mehr business und
enterprise drauf steht um so schlimmer ist es endlich also das geilste in der
richtung was wir einfach auf der arbeit war mal muss ich jetzt gucken ja doch
das ist so lange her das schon paar jahre das kann jetzt zählen
ja den storage von ibm und du musstest du musst ja bald dieses ja so ultra
business wahnsinnig teuer storage mit wartung und so was und dass du selbst
nichts machen kannst ist halt der richtige admin zugang für firmware
updates und sachen ist halt geschützt das darf nur ein zertifiziert der ibm
service techniker machen da an der storage irgendwie dran gehen und bis
wir dann irgendwann mal geguckt haben mit welchem username der sich anmeldet
und ich krieg ich krieg gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen
zumindest konnte man einfach auch ich glaube mit dem karl abfragen was was
der sache ist und hat das password raus gekriegt ich glaube dass wenn ich das
wenn ich das so richtig zusammen kriege lag das da dran der techniker da
brauchte halt irgendwie ein klein zertifikat oder sowas aber es hat
gereicht es hat gereicht wenn du dir irgendein random zertifikat generiert
hast allerdings der aussteller oder der der
besitzer musste richtig sein es wurde nicht überprüft auf dem storage ob das
auch wirklich richtig ausgestellt ist war total bescheuert da hatten wir admin
zugang und hätten theoretisch den ibm support nicht mehr gebraucht was
natürlich keiner wollte weil der ibm support ja auch nicht nur eingekauft
wird um was zu machen sondern auch dass man jemand hat auf dem man zeigen kann
wenn was nicht funktioniert ja und dann kam irgendwann mal dann kam
irgendwann mal der ibm techniker am wochenende und wollte firmware update
machen und das ist super secret special business
firmware die kann man nicht einfach im internet downloaden oder so also sprich
dem haben sie dann aus israel die firmware geschickt die hat aber sich auf
auf auf auf dem ibm laptop auf den usb stick kopiert bevor er zu uns gefahren
ist und als er dann bei uns war hat er den usb stick stick zwischen kannte vom
fahrstuhl also wenn man wenn fahrstuhl aufgeht ist ja so ein kleiner kleine
lücke zwischen tür und fahrstuhl also fahrstuhl und dann komplett die tür auf
und so eine kleine lücke zwischen fahrstuhl und stockwerk dann das
geschafft beim aussteigen sein usb stick mit firmware update in diese lücke zu
schmeißen und dann ist nicht einfach nur der usb stick in die lücke gefallen und
im fahrstuhl schacht runter sondern in die schüssel unterm fahrstuhl
da lag der ibm firmware usb stick bis zum montag in der schüssel im fahrstuhl
da wurde es mit firmware update am wochenende nix
ja der hat es verkackt der hat es richtig verkackt
ja ja so der 2217 ist nie viel geschmiert ja könnte man so sagen ja es ist
2017 ich bin ehrlich gesagt relativ müde jetzt schon da sind ja auch fertig
es hat halt deutlich länger gedauert als ich gedacht habe weil uns der raspberry
zwischendrin verreckt ist weiße die dass das booten von ssd nicht mal
funktioniert hat ja wenn ich so überlege es gab schon einige merkwürdige
sachen mit enterprise business support und und leuten
aber eigentlich so unter bestrichen sagen umso umso mehr sache als ganz toll
enterprise und umso mehr enterprise business draufsteht umso schlimmer ist
das zeug
hatte schon mal von euch mal die große ehre lotus notes benutzen zu dürfen
eines der größten kackbusiness enterprise software pakete die es
überhaupt so gibt lotus notes teufel also wenn man wenn man an so was glauben
würde ja dann wäre wirklich lotus wer der teufel in software gestaltet quasi
das ist echt das schlimmste was also eines der schlimmsten sachen diese
überhaupt gibt lotus notes
ja leider gibt es die gibt es noch ja bei uns jetzt nicht mehr aber wir hatten
den kram lang genug welche schutzart wäre das dann für den
usb stick boar ip 67 könnte könnte hinkommen
kennst du eine gute open source sccm variant was ist ein sccm die
abkürzung sagt mir nix sccm system center configuration manager
das ist windows zeug da kenne ich nicht da kenne ich mich nicht mit aus mit der
mann von dino aus windows klaunst wenn das klaunste ein wenn aus kleines
deployen kann keine ahnung habe ich mich nie mit auseinandergesetzt keine
ahnung nicht zu sagen absolut kein schimmer
was was auch ein unfall ist sind die shops von flying uwe bestimmt nur die
allerbesten administratoren da geht nicht so ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
viele webshops
nix taugen leute meine frage an euch was ist denn die beste shop platform wenn
jemanden den shop aufmachen will der allerdings einfach nur klicken kann
shopify das hatte ich auch schon ja gibt es sonst irgendwas shop
ok shopify habe ich auch schon gesehen shopify haben wir gepenteste das sieht
echt gut aus und das ist das das nicht schlecht ja shopify habe ich ihm
letztendlich auch empfohlen letztens aber nur weil ich den absoluten low
brain move gemacht habe und habe das erste genommen was ich bei reddit als
empfehlung gefunden habe und das war shopify und das hat ihn letztendlich
letztendlich auch überzeugt weil sie eine trial gibt und sonst was anscheinend
ist er happy mit mit mit mit shopify jetzt
und weil ich schon mal gehört hatte naja wie gesagt 22 21 war schön dass so viele
leute wieder am start waren auch bei dem nicht ganz so mainstream thema
max was hältst du von der k was quichon k2 tastatur
nix oder keine ahnung weiß ich nicht habe ich nie ausprobiert also ich habe
ja auf der arbeit immer noch meine ducky one skyline mit mit mit mit keypad also
mit mit num block die ist super die kann man echt nur empfehlen
huge tastatur also im wahrsten sinne das wort ich wollte jetzt ein massive das
im wahrsten sinne das wort also mit dem ding kannst du leute erschlagen wenn du
willst dass das ist richtig richtig schwer und stabil das teil genau das teil
mit num block daheim habe ich ja mittlerweile jetzt eine logitech was war
es die 502 ne wo steht das überhaupt logitech g512 ja das sieht ähnlich aus
wie ja ich glaube das ist die das das ist die genau das ist die ohne ohne
handballenauflage wo ich mir noch so eine handballenauflage davor gekauft oder
oder nein mit handballenauflage die aber nicht dran ist die einfach so
rum wackelt wo man sich dran gewöhnen muss ja genau genau stimmt so eine habe
ich genau hier mit dieser handballenauflage die die rum wackelt oder
was den g513 die sieht sich aber echt ähnlich ja doch ja ja die ist es
geben wir das den karbon an die an die kiste kann ich mich noch erinnern genau
so eine habe ich die ist auch nicht schlecht die finde ich ganz gut
davor hatte ich nur eine korsa aber die war scheiße also die war wirklich muss
muss ich jetzt wirklich zu hart sagen wie es klingt die war richtig kacke die hier
das einzig gute an der war eine ordentliche handballenauflage die auch
fest dran war und viel zu teuer richtig die also die war müll die tasten waren
ganz merkwürdig so die kann die tasten kommen megaklein vor obwohl die
wahrscheinlich gar nicht viel kleiner sind als die anderen tasten auch ich
habe mich ja damals im stream drüber ausgelassen was ich daran müll fanden
kriegst jetzt aus dem kopf gar nicht mehr zusammen haben wir zumindest nicht
gefallen also die korsa macrosoftware ist totaler müll was war das denn was war
denn chat vielleicht wirst du jetzt noch was ging mir denn so sehr auf den keks
auf dieser tastatur dass ich sie auf dass ich sie quasi nach einem halben
jahr obwohl der kram taumäßig teuer ist wieder rausgeschmissen was war das denn
auch mal es gab so 23 sachen die mich so genervt haben an der tastatur dass ich
gesagt das kann ich mir nicht mehr geben doppelte tast der chat der chat weiß
wieder bescheid exzellent big brain chat genau die haben tasten die er tasten
doppelt gedrückt
und gerade und gerade steuerung v hat sie v hat sie doppelt gedrückt also wenn
ich was copy pasten wollte hat ich den scheiß teilweise doppel und dreifach
drin ja ne das das war müll doppelte doppel tasten anschläge
ja wirklich total ermisst ja also die war bestimmt defekt möglich aber bei dem
preis das nicht der weg damit die dati die probleme hat die logitech tastatur
hier nicht über die kann ich mich bis jetzt nicht beschweren
max guckt ihr mal was farben die also die tastatur namen wenn echt immer
abgedreht das hört sich an wie den berg wo einer hochklettert war millow v a
acht sieben und acht meter beim berg eher müllhaufen sieben und drei sieben und acht
meter überhaupt finde ich nur eine dati tastatur wenn ich danach suche
das sieht das sieht verdächtig nach nach der dati tastatur aus fast schon
das sieht sehr ähnlich aus wie meine dati skyline
die andere farben was richtig nice ist und warum ich auch jedem die diese
tastatur empfehlen kann zu der frage mit ob es nicht zu laut ist auf der arbeit
kann ich gleich was sagen also das ist ja exakt die ich auch mit dem numpad warum
ich jedem diese tastatur empfehlen kann der die dati zum arbeiten verwendet die
tasten fühlen sich wie beschreiben wie kann ich das am besten beschreiben die
tasten fühlen sich kühl an ich weiß es ist total bescheuert beschreibung ja die
tasten fühlen sich fest fest und kühl und und griffig an also ganz
merkwürdig ich kann es jetzt nicht anders beschreiben aber du kannst darauf tippen und
du hast nicht das gefühl dass du schon eine halbe stunde getippt hast oder dass
du da jetzt schon seit einer halben stunde deinen finger drauf liegen hast
oder so das gefühl hast du nicht und tatsächlich ein nachteil ist wenn du
da richtig drauf haust hier auf die tasten bei also hier bei der logitech geht
es noch auch die keycaps sind auch toll also die da geht nichts da löst sich
nix ab lustigerweise bei der das war auch so
nicht bei der korsar tastatur haben sich schon angefangen oben die
beschriftung abzulösen auf den auf dem auf dem f-knopf war die betrifft schon
fast ab da nur halbjahr also wenn er darauf richtig in die
tastatur haust dann schwingt das metall da unten drunter und die tasten klicken
ganz schön was man machen kann ist man kann sich so kleine gummiringe kaufen
und die drunter machen und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht ich habe mir gummiringe
unter die numblock enter taste gemacht control entfernen oder tasten die ich
gerne hemmere dass ich den leuten bei mir auf der arbeit nicht zu sehr auf den
kicks gehen also die tasten die ich besonders hemmere da habe ich in gummi
habe ich gummiringel drunter gemacht
und ihr kennt ja ich neige ja zu auf die numblock enter tasten zu drücken also
ich gebe ja ganz gerne mal was ein und wenn ich dann gucke ich mir das noch
mal an und wenn ich sehe ah der befehl passt so dann haue ich halt gerne mal auf
die enter tasten und das ist nervig mit der tastatur wenn da kein gummiring
drunter ist aber die kann ich zum arbeiten wirklich bedenkenlos empfehlen
das ist einer der besten tastaturen die ich je hatte zum spielen daheim habe ich
mir die nicht gekauft ich hätte mir sofort wieder gekauft die sache ist nur
die es gibt keine ordentliche macrosoftware dafür man kann damit ein
bisschen rum tricksen es hat einen eingebauten makromodus mit
einem switch hinten dran und das hat auch die möglichkeit dass man es gibt
da so ein Arduino makroprogrammierding die sache bei mir war bloß ich brauche
halt eine makro oder ich hätte gerne eine macrosoftware die halt auch ein
bisschen ins betriebssystem integriert ist zum beispiel wenn ich in vm war bin
soll das ein anderes profil aktivieren wie wenn ich unter windows bin oder so
was in der richtung also hier daheim hat mir die makro geschichte gefehlt aber
rein zum arbeiten ist das ding super und auch gar nicht so teuer billiger
als die ganzen rgb gaming spezial dinger an tastaturen
ich wollte jetzt schon seit zehn minuten oft gehen ich habe es dreimal
angesetzt so nach dem autor ich gehe jetzt auf ich gehe jetzt wirklich auf
wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen oder spätestens übermorgen im stream hast du
was im internet was man testen könnte außer den mail code ich habe überhaupt
nichts im internet ich habe gar nix gibt nichts der das der mail
server den betreibt betreib ich gar nicht das macht den mord ich habe gar
nix
ich habe eine domain auf der nix drauf ist mit nahm mit einer testseite von
nitrado
naja aber ansonsten habe ich nix wurde wurde mal ausprobieren könntest
wir machen jetzt schlussleute ich muss jetzt echt auf wir sehen uns dann morgen
oder übermorgen spätestens übermorgen also aller spätestens übermorgen ist
sonntag also aller spätestens eh sonntag morgens zum aufwach stream aber
wahrscheinlich morgen auch schon mal im lauf des tages wir sehen uns temple
ritter zwei monate excellent subscription dankeschön
nice ab und ich schaue mal schnell nicht dass ich noch anderen sub vergessen
habe das wäre nämlich ziemlich low
ne habe ich nicht zum glück alles klar also macht es gut wir sehen uns zu
tschüss also auch outro musik braucht ihr natürlich sonst sonst kommt wieder
sebaru ansagt er kann nicht schlafen oder sowas das wollen wir ja nicht das
wollen wir nicht
also bis denn macht's gut
m
Das war's für heute.